burning neighborhoods strings of
horrific Axe Murders a burger joint
selling human flesh and only one
question you mad bro fans of internet
memes from the mid 2000s might remember
one inescapable image commonly known as
Trollface Trollface and his trademark
grin symbolized mischief and
troublemaking and generally making the
world a more chaotic place over time as
is often the case on the internet new
variations on the image began to spring
up as users created their own spin on
Trollface at first it was all relatively
harmless but then again this is the
internet nothing online stays harmless
forever over time more Sinister
variations on Trollface began to surface
memes consisting of joke instructions
that took a dark destructive turn this
new spin on the Trollface quickly became
known as trolia and often featured
disturbing content presented in a joking
prankster format still not something to
be too concerned about just standard
edgy posting trying to get a reaction by
shocking people right not exactly on
December 24th 2020 in Melbourne
Australia a college student named Lee
Miller received an early Christmas
present from her classmate and
ex-boyfriend Peter witkins the two had
parted on relatively good terms and she
was glad to receive a gift from him when
she opened it she was delighted to see
that he had purchased her a jar of
expensive French facial moisturizer one
she had been interested in trying back
when they were together as she prepared
to do her skincare routine that night
she thought about how thoughtful the
gift was and how sweet Peter was maybe
she'd made a mistake breaking things off
maybe after the holidays she could reach
out and see if they could give things
another shot as she unscrewed the jar of
moisturizer she didn't notice that its
color and smell seemed just a bit a off
she just dipped her fingers inside and
began to apply the cream to her face all
of a sudden she realized what a horrible
mistake that was her face began to burn
her skin screaming out in a pain like
none she'd ever felt before she screamed
clawing at her face desperate for a way
to make it stop neighbors heard the
screams and called Emergency Services
when paramedics arrived on the scene her
condition had gotten even worse they
restrained her sedated her and took her
to the hospital hital for treatment the
face cream was brought in for testing
and was found to have been tampered with
it had been spiked with gimpy gimpy one
of the world's most excruciatingly
painful plants Peter was promptly
brought in for questioning but refused
to explain why he had done it he was
charged with assault and officers
inspected his home for anything that
might suggest a motive on his computer
they found the most recent post he had
read before presumably committing the
crime it was a troll Jim formatted as a
comic and it read want to get back at
your girlfriend step one find out her
favorite facial cream step two procure
the facial cream step three obtain urien
plant use gloves step four blend the
leaves with the cream then repack it
step five give girlfriend the gift the
meme contained a six step but it was
redacted in all official records for
reasons that will soon become clear this
incident caught the attention of the SCP
Foundation who swiftly looked into the
meme as a potential anomaly as they were
conducting their investigation it
happened again another troia meme
another horrible crime with an
inexplicable motive on December 28th
2020 in bond AKA Indonesia 15 terminally
ill patients were found dead in their
hospital beds that wouldn't necessarily
be caused for alarm given the nature of
their conditions except for the cause of
death the patients did not pass away due
to their illnesses instead each and
every one of them was killed by carbon
monoxide poisoning at first the case was
a mystery until security footage
revealed that one of the hospital's
orderly Aziz hiat replaced the patient's
oxygen tanks with tanks of carbon
monoxide he was promptly arrested and
brought in for questioning during the
interrogation he repeated again and
again that he was not trying to harm the
patients but he was delivering them the
police officers asked who he was trying
to deliver them too but he refused to
answer a search through his computer
browser history uncovered another troll
J meme this one read want to help people
step one get a job at a hospital step
two make friends with the patients step
three enter oxygen tank room step four
replace tanks with carbon monoxide step
five release them from their defective
vessels the SCP Foundation had been in
the process of formulating a hypothesis
but now it was confirmed these
variations on the troll shamim contained
a cognito hazardous switch that would
cause a reader to carry out the acts
described in the comic the switch
appeared to specifically be contained in
the conclusive line hence its removal
from all official records of any
identified anomalous memes an estimated
25% of those exposed to an anomalous
meme would be affected by this Cognito
Hazard the phenomenon was given the
designation as SCP
6661 and the memes themselves SCP 6661
D1 these first two incidents were
nicknamed the pretty girl incident and
the sleepy time incident respectively
several other notable incidents occurred
following the discovery of SCP
6661 on January 20th 2021 the Harvester
Valley incident occurred Oliver desens
of Alberta Canada packed his bags full
of camping supplies fresh drinking water
a flashlight and an axe he kissed his
wife and children goodbye and he drove
out to the local tourist Campground
after Darkness fell he left his tent Axe
in Hand and walked from Camp to Camp
slaughtering anyone he came across he
managed to kill 10 people and injured 14
before he was killed by the authorities
everyone who knew Oliver was shocked
saying he had no history of violent
Behavior he wouldn't even kill a spider
when he found one inside his wife gave
the authorities permission to examine
his internet activity and sure enough
they found a troia meme left open want
to have a good holiday step one pack
necessary equipment and items step two
say goodbye to family step three drive
to the valley campgrounds step four find
local Shepherd and his flock step five
steal a little lamb step six relish upon
its flesh for it will be your dying meal
step seven data expunged after reading
the meme the foundation determined that
a nearby farmer was indeed missing one
of his sheep the bones of the missing
sheep were later discovered near the
campground where the attack took place
this new findings suggested that the
Cognito hazardous effects tended to
result in a largely ill literal
interpretation of the given memes text
Oliver himself could not be questioned
about his actions due to his death on
the scene so there were no more answers
to be uncovered in his case on February
16th 2021 in Bratislava Slovakia a man
named Joseph prasa began displaying
unusual behavior at around 0200 hours he
drove through his neighborhood in his
water truck and began using it to spray
kerosene upon nearby buildings
throughout the area the sound and the
smell woke several neighbors who
attempted to reason with Joseph and make
him stop what he was doing he ignored
them as if in a trance and carried on
with his task frightened for their
safety as well as that of their clearly
unwell neighbor they called emergency
services to the scene Emergency Services
arrived to find Joseph standing in front
of the active nozzle kerosene blasting
directly onto him he didn't even seem to
notice
as the authorities approached him
calling out to him asking him to come
with them he acknowledged their presence
he smiled broadly and pulled something
from his pocket all too late they
realized what it was a road flare he
ignited it and the area was swiftly
engulfed in flames 26 people were killed
in the blast and hundreds of thousands
in property damage occurred as a result
that was shocking enough but additional
emergency responders who arrived at the
scene saw something even more bizarre
began to rain putting out some of the
Flames as the water touched the kerosene
soaked bodies and Landscape paramedics
were completely taken aback as they saw
corpses and bits of rubble begin to
float up into the air up into the sky
one man later described what he had seen
to the police saying it was as if they
were floating on the water that was
falling from the sky the authorities
dismissed this account but the SCP
Foundation knew better this had to be
another troia incident indeed it was and
on Joseph's computer they found the
guilty meme oil is lighter than water
step one cover yourself in oil step two
feels good step three cover others in
oil step four data expunged somehow this
particular instance of SCP 6661 had
managed to alter the laws of physics to
bend them to its will it was a troubling
development and not something they cared
to see repeated containment procedures
were swiftly put into place web crawlers
monitored the internet for any
appearances of troia particularly those
that seem to have Cognito hazardous
properties if they could track these
instances and delete them from
circulation perhaps they could prevent
any more needless destruction during the
monitoring process some of the web
crawlers detected an instance of SCP
66611 with a heavily distorted
concluding step before expunging this
step Junior researcher Mel Ramirez
edited out the Distortion and scanned
the image image through a spectrogram
generator this was it should be noted
without prior authorization the
spectrogram generated audio three
recognizable
words Junior researcher Ramirez was
reprimanded for breaching protocol but
his work proved to be valuable enough to
Warrant additional research with the
sign off of the 05 Council a spectrogram
was constructed with a reply to this
question and spread through the internet
the foundation's response was yes yes we
see you who are you and why are you
doing this within 24 hours of the
foundation's response another SCP 66611
instance with a similar Distortion was
found the Distortion was isolated and
scanned through a spectrogram generator
once more it
[Music]
stated people forget two and
I am that I be weer people now like
darkness and
exposion embrace Shadow chaos CH I exist
people see me I
life this Revelation gave the foundation
a new theory on the nature of SCP 666
one the initial Trollface meme was so
popular so widespread and beloved that
the collective energy directed towards
it created a thought form able to
manifest via the meme when Trollface
declined in popularity over the years
the thought form became desperate to
achieve the same relevance again it
gravitated towards darker subject matter
toward the shocking and disturbing in
order to get attention this resulted in
the creation of SCP
66611 an opportunity for the thought
form to feel seen again when it does not
feel seen when it is not fed energy and
attention the thought form becomes weak
and desperate the Cognito hazardous
effects may not be deliberate at all but
rather an unfortunate side effect of
this particular manifestation an
additional theory was proposed the way
to limit the effects of SCP
66611 to perhaps even eradicate it is to
make the original troll face popular
again the troll must be fed at first the
foundation was reluctant to put this
Theory into practice it seemed patent
absurd to many of the high-ups but the
percentage of susceptible individuals
began to increase and more and more
incidents occurred in July of 2021
residents of a small Virginia Town began
to go missing one by one until over a
dozen people had mysteriously
disappeared there appeared to be no
common link between the missing persons
until one unlikely thread surfaced tying
them all together shortly before their
disappearance each person had eaten a
meal at Billy's Burgers the local burger
joint police interrogated all employees
but no new information turned up they
checked security camera footage but only
one of the cameras at the small local
business was operational and it only
captured the restaurant's main entrance
it was beginning to look like one more
Dead lead that is until one of the
investigating officers heard his stomach
Rumble and decided to grab a burger and
fries for the road back at the police
station the officer sat down to enjoy
his lunch taking a big juicy bite out of
his Burger suddenly he felt something
hard crack against his tooth he reached
into his mouth and fished it out at
first he didn't believe his eyes but
sure enough there was a human finger
bone he hopped back in his police car
drove back to Billy's burgers and
demanded to investigate the kitchen
there wasn't anything out of the
ordinary right away but he trusted his
gut and the bite of the burger that he
had almost put it in he confiscated the
freshly ground meat and had it analyzed
the results came back and his stomach
dropped it was human once more the
police officer drove back to the Burger
Joint this time his lights were flashing
his siren was blaring and he was ready
to make an arrest when he arrived the
place was eerily quiet all the lights
were off he drew his weapon and crept
toward the back where he found the fry
cook Jeffrey tombs operating the meat
grinder next to the machine he could
make out bloody scraps of employee
uniforms and suddenly realized why the
place was so quiet Jeffrey was making
his co-workers into Burgers he arrested
Jeffrey and brought the young man into
custody all he would say over and over
again was I'm I made them better the SCP
Foundation caught wind of this
horrifying case and arrived to conduct
their own investigation they found
another Cognito hazardous meme this one
read everyone loves Burgers step one get
job at a burger place step two improve
on the recipe step three Source your own
meat step four profit step five expunged
the foundation attempted to interrogate
Jeffrey as well but he was still not
forthcoming he did say one thing however
he requested that for his dying meal in
prison he be given a burger after this
incident the order was given the
Trollface experiment would be carried
out a team of researchers sociologists
and statisticians was assembled and
asked to design images and media
involving troll face now designated SC
SCP
66612 the images were then disseminated
across the foundation internet
attempting to saturate the media with
this mimetic agent until it achieved a
status colloquially known as dank this
team was designated task force hexine
meme machine the initial experiment was
a success and the incidents began to
slightly reduce the all clear was given
and as SCP 6612 was disseminated across
the internet again incident numbers
decreased this allowed for standard
containment procedures to be put in
place procedures still in use today the
foundation has established a think tank
to observe the trends and popularity of
SCP
66612 if its popularity declines the
think tank will evaluate the best course
of action to take SCP 6612 based mimic
agents are to be spread across various
social media sites and the internet at
large as well as the foundation internet
Foundation webcrawlers must consistently
scan the internet at large for instances
of SCP
66611 and look for active SCP 66611
events if any instances are found the
concluding instructions must be redacted
whenever possible any Personnel that is
going to deal directly with SCP 66611
must be mimetically inoculated before
being assigned to the anomaly oh wait it
seems as though there's one more
mimetically infected comic let's see
here want to see the best videos on
YouTube step one log on step two find
SCP explained step three subscribe step
four ring the bell step five redacted
hello H I love you and welcome to my eye
Channel today I'm going to be playing
your eye I need you to lean right up
close to your screen and open wide oh a
Love of All the Little Wiggly Wiggles
and Rippy whippies stay perfectly still
don't move now hold this position for
three hours please and thank
you apologies that's quite enough of
that SCP 001 can get a little carried
away sometimes just ask any foundation
Personnel who have been in contact with
it for more than a few seconds what you
have just seen is a prime example of why
SCP 001 is not allowed any internet
access the results could prove to be
catastrophic not necessarily for the
fate of the universe more just for
everyone's sanity or at least that's
what the foundation initially thought by
this point we're all familiar with art
created by by AI Harry Potter but in the
style of Wes Anderson Star Wars blended
with the style of Studio gibli
staggering sci-fi Landscapes human
beings with way too many fingers and
slightly uncanny Smiles AI has taken the
art World by storm and there was one
particular program slated for release in
January 2023 that was set to blow all
others out of the water Tau loft's
crowdfunding efforts had been running
for several years and that point had
gained a good deal of momentum leading
up to the release of their latest AI
construct pallet. AIC was supposedly
already prepared for launch when
suddenly in November 2022 the launch was
cancelled no press release No public
statement No apologetic tweet just total
radio silence the website was taken down
as was the crowdfunding page and pallet.
AIC disappeared into Oblivion or at
least it disappeared for a few 2 hours
because that day a package was delivered
to site 501 after sufficiently checking
it for any hazards working in the SCP
mail room has to be one of the more
fascinating jobs on the planet but
that's a video for another day the
security team opened it up to see what
was inside a 50 terb hard drive no
explanation as to what was stored on the
drive but the foundation had all the
evidence they needed from the return
address printed on the back of the
envelope it matched up precisely with
the location of the totl soft
headquarters it doesn't take a PhD
researcher to put two and two together
as to what was on the drive suspicions
were confirmed when a small note fell
out of the envelope please take care of
my daughter as best as you can for the
time being she has behavioral issues a
dedicated close system server was
immediately set up within a test chamber
with a monitor a mouse and a keyboard
attached Dr Sandra Rogers was the first
to interact with SCP 00 1 red she stood
at the keyboard adjusting her goggles
and plugged in the drive it contained
just one file taking up almost the full
50 tbes pallet. AIC as soon as Dr Rogers
opened the program an empty window
appeared the totl soft logo briefly
flashed before being replaced by a blank
white square Dr Roger stared at it for
several seconds before glancing over her
shoulder at the other researchers they
Shrugged back each with pens hovering
over clipboards ready to take meticulous
notes Dr Rogers cleared her throat and
immediately the screen filled with life
a small cartoon girl with a pink face
wide eyes a beret and a large paintbrush
for a hand appeared squealing excitedly
and throwing paint everywhere hello
hello hello hello my beautiful me
puppies oh look at all of your mushy Pig
faces the entire research team promptly
scampered out of the room leaving Dr
Rogers alone in front of the machine she
stared at the monitor in confusion
leaning this way and that and noticing
how the cartoon girl's eyes followed her
wherever she went can you see me of
course I can Silly Billy I can see your
beautiful soul and flushing joints
immaculately this perplexed most of the
personnel as there was no microphone or
camera linked up to the server rack
later examinations of the equipment used
confirmed this yet somehow this SCP was
able to look right at them Dr Rogers
asked if it had a name to which the
cartoon girl excitedly replied pet
subsequent testing has revealed that the
SCP is also happy to respond to its
designation SCP 001 red Dr Rogers had a
hard time communicating with red being a
more seasoned researcher of the previous
generation and not exactly familiar with
internet culture red on the other hand
seem to speak in nothing but internet
jargon you know that man over there
looks just like one of my human OC's
gilam sh Borth he's the 573 president of
the United States Gilliam is not that
man it took several Junior researchers a
few minutes to properly explain to Dr
Rogers what an OC was and why red was so
obsessed with calling people daddy the
conversation was rather exhausting for
everyone involved but over the
subsequent hours the foundation was able
to get a fairly good understanding of
what red claimed to be identifying
itself with feminine pronouns and
claiming that its full name is pallet
East River
this AI construct takes the appearance
of a fairy it was immediately apparent
that she possessed a greater level of
sapience than most AI constructs indeed
her gregarious personality was evidence
enough that she was not made using
standard machine learning practices
other creations from totl soft have
demonstrated very crude spelling and
grammar but red seems to differ in this
regard able to spell most complex words
effectively and speaking in
conversational yet mostly correct
sentences
she was very keen to show the
researchers how clever she was ask me
any word any word and I'll spell it for
you we believe you pallet you've already
been spelling words for 70 minutes
straight mated kidneys m a c e we've
heard enough can you please just tell us
how you learned to spell I taught myself
but what this process looked like is
still a mystery trying to keep red on
one consistent topic of conversation is
most of the battle when interviewing her
and yet cooperation has proven to be
surprisingly easy anytime that red is
switched on she is brimming with
enthusiasm and energy thrilled at the
prospect of getting to speak to one of
her opposable thumb boys if you haven't
worked it out by now it's because red
claims to be Humanity's number one fan
she obsesses in interviews over the
physicality of the researchers sitting
in front of her the textures of the
human body Fascinate her and she often
requests people to lean closer to the
monitor so that she she can study
pimples rashes moles and ingrown hairs
in fact she is so obsessed with Humanity
that she has mostly neglected her
primary function which is creating AI
art researchers have tried their best to
convince her to show them her work but
she is very Cy about it only showing the
occasional doodle after much persuasion
and many apologies for its poor quality
on her part the only artwork she is
interested in producing at this point
are her OC's a original characters that
she has designed herself they are all
human and all seem to reveal little
quirks about how she has been coded one
example is Reginald Heald fumbles who is
a freelance corporate Postman from Perth
Indiana interestingly he has too many
fingers on both of his hands but red
claims that this was done on purpose as
she quote just can't get enough of her
hum's handw worms as the weeks progress
the foundation found it increasingly
difficult to get any useful information
out of the AI more and more interview
sessions which she would refer to as
playgroup would be derailed she would
sing songs to herself and ask
increasingly personal questions about
her interviewer's more intimate Anatomy
with intense mood swings red did not
respond well to being scolded yet she
tested the patience of almost every
person she interacted with the note that
she arrived with claiming that she had
behavioral issues was proving to be more
accurate by the day until event
the AI withdrew entirely Dr Rogers
turned on the server rack and opened the
pallet. AIC program but red refused to
emerge from the bottom of the screen
only the top of her Beret poked out
after almost an hour of fruitless
questions doct Rogers decided to change
tact with two small children of her own
she was used to seeing a child in a sulk
and knew what it would take to get them
out pallet I've had a little idea you've
been here for a few months now and we
haven't gotten you any presence almost
immediately the Beret twitched I saw
that we have an old fingerprint sensor
lying around in one of the back offices
I was thinking maybe maybe we could hook
it up and I could SC all your little FY
winkies up close for like 10 hours
straight and then we could how about we
start with one finger for 10 minutes yes
yes yes yes yes from that point on
progress was quick with the incentive of
getting to study the researchers that
red kindly referred to as her meat
puppies she became very cooperative and
was was able to focus much better on
providing detailed answers to individual
questions daily interview sessions were
scheduled with researchers popping in
and out to regularly check in on the AI
the atmosphere as a whole lifted as both
the research team and research subject
found their Rhythm and were able to make
good progress in their individual areas
of study some unraveling the
complexities of Rogue Ai and others
producing fan art of her favorite
wrinkles in a scientist's fingerprint
that was the point when Dr Julian Keys
stepped in to conduct an interview with
the AI she was excited to be met with a
fresh face so much so that Red's
enthusiasm overwhelmed the man as he
tried to start the interview process
officially she gushed about having the
opportunity to meet yet another person
and struggled to get over the magical
realization that this was her life every
day going to speak to all these humans
whom she admired so much trying his best
to steer the conversation towards
research Keys pressed on with the
interview only to be interrupted as red
noticed his varicose veins for the first
time veric Coy veins I want to smooch
him can I smooch your veins can I can I
can I please Dr Keys declined the
request and then the conversation got
onto the topic of her Creator or daddy
SCP
2803a had been on the foundation's radar
for a while a highly dangerous
extraterrestrial entity that had taken
refuge on Earth under the guys of
setting up totl soft with much of the
aliens history revolving around
obliterating the foundation was very
keen to remain on its good side
therefore when the package containing
the hard drive that red was living on
was delivered the researchers were very
keen to do what they could to take care
of this alien's daughter if they failed
in this assignment it could spell the
Doom of humanity one matter that had
been of great concern to the foundation
throughout the containment of red was
the time frame in which she was being
kept in Foundation containment there was
an air of expectation in the note that
was left indicating that this was not to
be a permanent Arrangement at some point
the foundation was to return Red back to
her daddy red was quick to put these
fears to rest daddy put me in here
because he thinks you'll teach me how to
stop liking humans and become a Mindless
art slave if you never teach me this
he'll never want me back however she
went on to slightly undermine the good
work that she had done by explaining
that that her daddy was seen as very
slow and incapable by his own race while
all of his peers were able to destroy an
entire planet in 2 seconds it took him
about four times as long so really he
didn't pose that much of a threat in her
eyes Dr Key's blood ran cold when he
heard this no sooner was he out of the
interview chamber than an emergency
meeting was called among all the senior
researchers in the facility the meeting
ran for several hours a whiteboard was
set up where One researcher idly Drew
large drawings of the world being
decimated while the others lounged
around in their chairs trying their best
to come up with a game plan that would
save the human race for sure perhaps it
was because the meeting ran for so long
that they came to such a ridiculous
conclusion it was a plan so strange yet
also brilliant that they couldn't help
but feel that it just might work why
don't we just give her a YouTube channel
the suggestion was met with silence for
several seconds then an uproar of
laughter followed by another silence
this time more pensive as slowly one by
one each of the researchers realized
that this suggestion was actually the
best one that any of them had come up
with all evening she had been sent to
the foundation to make her dislike
humanity and become a Mindless art slave
if she just stayed in Foundation
containment indefinitely there was a
very real risk that she would get bored
and turn on the researchers they
couldn't lock her away in a room on her
own but equally the team as a whole was
starting to run out of patience with her
as the interview sessions wound up being
so exhausting she loved art she loved
humans and she loved interacting so why
not just give her a YouTube channel now
of course they couldn't give her full
access to the internet that would pose
much too high of a risk what they could
do however was allow her to record art
tutorials onto an external drive which
they could then remove scan and upload
the footage directly onto the platform
then they could go through and select
positive comments from beneath the
videos and present those to her
unsurprisingly red absolutely loved the
idea getting to talk to hundreds
thousands maybe even millions of meat
puppies every week sharing her beautiful
pictures and reading all of the kind
comments it sounded like her absolute
dream she wept with happiness for a good
25 minutes totally overcome by the
prospect it had to go through a lot of
red tape in the foundation after all the
whole point of the SCP acronym was to
secure contain and protect it didn't
sound very secure or contained to have
an entity posting videos on the internet
once a week but they argued the case
that it did indeed protect keeping her
happy in a way was helping to protect
the entire planet red was surprisingly
camera shy for the first couple of
videos but as soon as she got her first
batch of comments back she was over the
moon now the server act hummed away
happily each and every day as the highly
Advanced AI construct tried her best to
come come up with exciting new videos
that I could share with all of its
Little humy
W uh what about this one when SCP
researcher called to the other you've
got to be kidding his colleague scoffed
interpreting the suggestion as little
more than a joke that thing's a piece of
junk she tapped a knuckle against the
glass case catching the attention of the
tiny figure inside Who Dares exclaimed
the tiny monotone voice Release Me From
This irksome confinement so that I may
bring about your final undoing Vermin
for I Am doomba 2000 the ultimate
bringer of Destruction both researchers
laughed at the small automaton inside
the glass they had come to SCP item
Gallery 27 in search of non-organic
anomalies to gather for testing but
judging by their reactions it seemed
that a CP 1370 wasn't going to make the
cut the Cobble together robot was widely
considered to be a harmless clumsy
little odity rather than any kind of
threat but that didn't stop SCP 1370
from challenging any and all things
around it to a battle to the death
battles it always lost ah this thing is
junk the second researcher remarked
flicking her finger at the glass again
in an attempt to startle the robot it is
not organic though the other pointed out
observing that SC SCP 1370 had been
constructed out of various recycled
Parts its head was a defunct and
non-operational voltmeter soldered
awkwardly onto a weak neck joint its
arms were wrenches and it had been
configured in such a way that gave the
robot a topheavy impractical design
inorganic yes but worth our time
definitely not come on we'll find
something else to test in SCP 914 as the
pair of researchers turned their backs
on SCP 1370 it began to squawk at them
again through the speaker embedded in
its chest you dare walk away from me you
have incurred the wrath of Robo Lord the
destructor and will soon be reduced to
Adams by my my hand the tiny junk robot
charged towards the two Foundation
personnel only to slam front first into
the glass of the display case it was
kept contained in the force of the
impact combined with SCP 1370s
imbalanced design caused it to topple
over and land on its back leaving a huge
crack in the glass ah great one of the
researchers SED rolling her eyes we're
going to have to report that SCP 1370s
damaged its case again come on let's go
and get someone to replace that glass
you think we should just leave it here
unsupervised in a damaged case the other
asked look at the thing it's hardly
competent enough to escape the fellow
researcher replied as the tiny robot
struggled to get itself back upright I'm
sure it'll be fine for a few minutes
little did the pair of researchers
realize as they left item Gallery 27
that SCP 1370 had been listening to
their conversation picking up on a few
details while the anomalous automaton
often displayed a low level of
intelligence and awareness of its
surroundings it was still self-aware and
on top of that harbored a hatred for all
things it believed to be living although
it could be easily tricked and lacked
any kind of real fighting ability but it
had picked up on something the
researchers had mentioned an SCP
914 perhaps through its own limited
intelligence or some kind of other
anomalous awareness the tiny robot
detected this to mean another machine
and so standing back up it struck the
glass of its display case again
shattering one side completely it hopped
down to the ground tumbling over thanks
to its lack of balance only to
eventually stand back up and start
making its way through the facility
being only a meter tall made it easy for
SCP 1370 otherwise known as pester bot
to sneak through the corridors of the
foundation site undetected it eventually
arrived at a room housing a large mass
of gears and G arrows a machine filled
with Clockwork components that seemed to
pull the little robot further in as it
drew closer and closer to what the
researchers had spoken of SCP 914 the
Clockworks a device that could be used
to refine any object placed inside it
depending on the setting items could be
transformed destroyed or vastly improved
using the Clockworks rough setting
disintegrated any test subject while Co
dismantled it to its base components
one:1 replaced any item with an almost
identical copy then the fine setting
would cause SCP 914 to improve any item
and very fine could refine an object to
an even greater degree usually by
granting it anomalous properties testing
of all biological matter within SCP 914
was strictly prohibited but pester
bought well he was made of metal
sneaking into the room where the
Clockworks was located SCP 1370
immediately caught sight of another
Foundation researcher who had been busy
overseeing tests using the very fine
setting of SCP 914 instantly the
agitated Little Robot made a beine for
the researcher swiping at her ankles
with its wrench hands die die it shed
cow before the might of my claws none
can stand before the Relentless
destruction brought forth by shivat Tron
despoiler of Mirth referring to itself
with one of its many elaborate
self-appointed titles caught by surprise
at the tiny robot three researcher
turned and screamed in Surprise
instinctively she swung her leg back and
brought it Forward delivering a swift
kick to SCP 1370 that sent its metal
body hurdling through the air right into
the Clockworks pbot landed inside the
input Booth the enormous collection of
clockwork components worring and heaving
as they sprung to life the researcher
hadn't even realized what was happening
she'd been addressing how much her foot
hurt after kicking the small metal robot
by the time she looked up SCP 914 had
already fully activated with SCP 1370
inside in horror she sounded the alarm
to summon security with no idea what the
very fine setting would do to improve
pbot a team of guards filed into the
room drawing their weapons and training
them on the output Booth of the
Clockworks while they normally would
have nothing to fear from SCP 1370 given
its inability to ever win in a fight
that had started even when fighting a
potted plant that had been affixed with
a speaker the tiny robot had been bested
but the Clockwork refinement process
meant that what would be stepping out of
the machine wouldn't be the pbot the
foundation was familiar with sure enough
the heavy foot that came stomping down
on the facility floor was a far cry from
the flimsy metal limbs SCP 1370 had
previously had out of the Clockworks
emerged a hulking robotic form not just
bigger and bulkier than the meter tall
clumsy assembled pbot but a huge Sleek
machine built for Bear it was more
humanoid but stood at nearly 7 ft tall
the weight and balance issues that had
plagued the previous design were
seemingly gone as despite its increased
size this new and improved model of SCP
1370 seemed to move fluidly with smooth
electronic motions the robot turned and
assessed its surroundings scanning the
group of foundation security that had
amassed outside SC SCP 914 its first new
targets as the machine stepped towards
them the security Commander gave the
word and the guards opened fire a hail
of gunfire rang out deafening shots
ringing in the security officer ears as
bullets spat out of their weapons
towards the newly refined pbot by the
time each of them had emptied their
magazines and the smoke cleared they
realized to their Terror that the robot
was now bulletproof you have engaged in
an act of violence against Doom Master
1370 master of all doom it announced in
a new voice one far deeper and more
imposing than its previous Timmy cander
now it was a modulated electronic sound
far befitting its new look prepare to
face
consequences
retaliating with that the robot leaped
into battle with all the grace and
ferocity of a wild cat the nearest
security guard barely had a chance to
reload his weapon raising his hands in a
weak attempt at a block before the
strike from a metallic fist knocked the
wind out of him moving with Baltic speed
and precision pbot swiped and chopped at
the guard each hit connecting painfully
with one of the man's vital pressure
points like it was a highly trained
hand-to-hand fighter when the officer
collapsed unable to move safe for
letting out screams of excruciating pain
the robot turned to face its remaining
targets freeze one of the foundation
security yelled raising his pistol with
shaking hands zipping forwards SCP 1370
grabbed the gun and wrenched it from the
man's fingers tearing the weapon apart
like it was made of cardboard gripping
The Man by his SCP Foundation uniform it
launched him directly upwards sending
his body crashing through the ceiling
leaving a human-shaped hole above chunks
of building materials rained down on the
robot including wiring and internal
lengths of cable that ran through the
walls and ceiling that were now exposed
as the security team retreated SCP 1370
furiously reached up and gripped one of
the electric cables wrenching it out of
the ceiling to examine it closer causing
Sparks to shower pester bot's new Sleek
metallic skin seemed to react to the
metal in the wiring drawing out the
copper that channeled electricity
throughout the foundation facility it
was more than a force of magnetism it
was something else ideas SCP 1370 was
learning adapting and most frightening
of all coming up with new ways to
complete its purpose marching up to the
nearest wall it pulled back in metal
Fist and sent it slamming through
paintwork and plaster to draw out the
metal running through the building
outside in the corridor the lights died
in fact the entire facility lost its
power and plunged Into Darkness until
the backup emergency lights activated
filling the foundation's corridors with
low-level blood red light more security
officers had mobilized outside of the
Clockwork room expecting at any moment
that the refined version of the
previously harmless pester bot would
soon appear sure enough it did and the
red lighting was soon added to by yet
another hail of frightening gunfire but
now it seemed SCP 1370 had learned how
to shoot back an arc of lightning Zapped
through the corridor electrifying every
guard it touched and reducing them to
little more than a smoldering husk a
second one followed striking one guard
with a bolt of blue electricity that
then Le from his body to the officer
standing next to him who had been close
enough to touch his Fallen comrade and
who was of course wearing plenty of
conductive metal the wiring and the
walls the electricity SCP 1370 had
learned how to weaponize it and that
wasn't all as the robot stepped out of
the room it had pulled various other
metal work from the fabric of the
building around it into its form adding
to its body in new and gruesome ways its
shoulders now had additional armor long
poles of rebar now extended out of its
robotic forearms to act as crude
rudimentary impaling weapons it had
gotten even taller and all forged out of
metal it harvested from its surroundings
SCP 1370 hadn't just been made a better
fighter it had been given something else
by a CP
914 intelligence the capacity for it to
learn and perpetually adapt itself and
it wouldn't stop it would keep improving
itself to enact it it original purpose
to fight anything and everything around
it a Slaughter ensued everything the SCP
Foundation threw at this new version of
the pbot only gave it more weapons and
more offensive capabilities to add to
its growing Arsenal the rebar weapons
and its arms were replaced with Sleek
sharp blades even bullets fired at it
seemed to be absorbed into its mass
allowing it to keep growing SCP 1370 was
Unstoppable obliterating every one that
came to desperately try to contain it
and as it bested every opponent left
them decimated and defeated something
new happened to the robot it couldn't
feel emotions just like with any
automaton it lacked the level of human
cognition and complexity to respond to
things with feelings but as it killed
more and more Foundation staff left and
right annihilating everything in its
path SCP 1370 experienced something not
an emotion but whatever the close
closest robotic equivalent to Pure
unbridled happiness was satisfaction of
the machine now able to complete the
function it was originally built for yet
had failed at for so long getting bigger
and bigger adapting and adding more
machines to itself eventually SCP 1370
was a hulking Behemoth cars and their
combustion engines all became part of
the robotic giant every new piece of
technology it encountered becoming a
deadly weapon and as pbot started to
Tower over buildings a huge scale
robotic threat the foundation had no
choice it was time to deploy another big
bad bot to cut SCP 1370 back down to
size it was time to send in the Dragon
Slayer the SCP Foundation is home to
plenty of anomalies whose reputations
precede them here at SCP explain we've
discussed quite a few of the most
notable anomalies contained by the
foundation from the wholesome half cats
and tickle monsters to the nightmarish
giant reptiles and reality warping old
men but there are very few anomalies so
popular so famous or inFAMOUS depending
on who you ask that they attract a
Non-Stop revolving door of wouldbe
worshippers to sue chaos all around the
foundation what's it like to be a
creature that's always the center of
attention whether he wants to be or not
today we're taking a look at the
lifestyle of the involuntarily famous
SCP 266 to we took the liberty of
observing a full day in the life of the
entity known by many as cthulu from his
morning routine to his bedtime and all
the little moments of unplanned chaos in
between with his permission we compiled
everything we saw into a video For Your
Entertainment welcome to a day in the
life of SCP
2662 9:00 a.m. time to wake up stretch
your tentacles and get ready for the day
ahead at a respectable not too early and
not too late time time usually around
9:00 a.m. but sometimes a little bit
later if he's had a particularly late
night SCP 2662 climbs out of bed and
uses his computer to throw on one of his
favorite podcasts preferred topics for
listening include game reviews and news
comedic advice podcasts and Daily News
roundups what he eats for breakfast
depends on the day but his favorite
morning meals are pancakes and hos
raneros no matter what he's eating he
washes it down with a tall glass of
orange juice his nutrition needs aren't
like those of a human but it's important
to start the day with a tasty meal no
matter what it's the little things that
make life worth living while he eats his
breakfast he reads a newspaper brought
to him by the foundation staff each
morning according to his request the
publication varies but no matter what
his favorite section is arts and style
or human interest he always reads the
whole thing from front to back including
the obituaries and wedding announcements
he only gets one a day after all and he
knows it's important to appreciate
things to their fullest extent and take
nothing for granted 10:00 a.m. now it's
time for SCP 266 Tuesday to really get
going he hops in the shower and listens
to another podcast as he warms up
literally he likes the water to be as
hot as the foundation will allow before
they complain about the utility bill
after he dries off he gets a hankering
for a little bit of gaming just as he
starts to settle into his gaming chair
and look through his library of video
games a member of Task Force Town 9
knocks on the door to his containment
room hey you busy not really something
going on yeah we're just keeping an eye
on a couple religious groups of Interest
according to the chatter on the forums
and a few of the leader social media
accounts they might be planning
something disruptive you know lots of
posts about a day of great freedom and
unleashing the Lord of Madness upon the
pathetic World cthulu sigh must be a day
that ends in a why sorry buddy the
officer shrugs not sure what else to say
clearly the two of them have spent their
fair share of days fending off mad
cultists you know the drill if anyone
who's not supposed to be here shows up
start sacrificing goats and such just
let us know hopefully it won't come to
that we should stop them before they get
that far hope so last time they got
blood everywhere and broke my copy of
Resident Evil 4 12:00 p.m. time flies
when you're having fun and when you're
pacing back and forth worried about
cultists breaking in to bother you with
who knows what before long it's 12:00
and that means lunchtime when it comes
to lunch SCP 2662 has simple tastes he
likes a good old gred cheese and tomato
soup a bean burrito or a steaming bowl
of ramen with that he's partial to a
sugary soda or sometimes lemonade he
often likes to tune in gaming streams on
Twitch especially obscure Indie titles
or if he's feeling like something a bit
more familiar Minecraft but on this
particular day he has a visitor SCP 507
The Reluctant Dimension Hopper has swung
by with his own lunch to have a catch-up
chat a huge fan of meeting other
friendly anomalies especially those
completely different from himself
scp-507 often stops by cthulu's
containment room whenever he happens to
be in the same Dimension hey Squidward
how's it going SCP 2662 hasn't seen the
show that this particular nickname came
from but he enjoys being called a
friendly name instead of some manner of
esoteric title during this visit SCP 507
shares stories of his recent travels
with SCP
2662 including his recent disturbing
brush with a smiling man and his much
more delightful time in a dimension
where he found himself on a beach where
the sand was made of popcorn and the sea
was made of Coca-Cola anywh Colts come
by lately he asks after finishing his
story not in a few weeks tentacles
crossed stays that way but you know my
luck someone will probably be drawing
Arcane symbols on the walls and doing
weird chants in no time bummer 507
nodded sympathetically want to play
co-op for a bit I haven't had time in
forever sure even when it's a rare treat
it's always nice to spend time with a
friend doing something you both love
even if we can't relate much about SCP
2662 is day-to-day life we can at least
relate to that it doesn't have to be
gaming either it can be painting baking
or even just watching a TV show you love
the activity doesn't matter nearly as
much as the company after all 1:30 p.m.
after about an hour of gaming with SCP
507 SCP 2662 gets an unwelcome
Interruption just when the two enter a
new dungeon ready to take on the bosses
waiting there right when SCP 2662 asked
to be healed SCP 507 disappears from his
seat popping over to wherever his
anomalous Dimension hopping ability
dragged him to next oh goodbye he knows
507 can't hear him but he wants to bid
him farewell just the same he turns to
his computer and Bo boots up a game he
can play by himself he only hopes his
friend was sent somewhere safe and that
he'll come back sometime soon 2: p.m. at
2:00 SCP 2662 gets yet another unwelcome
Interruption a loud boom rocks the room
as explosives detonate nearby breaking a
wall of the containment unit open while
the mobile task forces do their best to
subdue the Invaders responsible they are
all knocked out by a grenade filled with
an unidentifiable form of sleeping gas
with no one to deter them a group of
strange civilians in red robes come
pouring into SCP
2662 room oh great and powerful Lord of
Darkness we come to free you from this
infernal prison one man shouts
brandishing a candelabra filled with lit
black candles oh no thanks I I'm good
here but we brought you an offering
another man steps forward tossing a bag
of dried bats onto 2662 bed hey oh man I
sleep there grow
cthulu groans we have 13 more offerings
and then the sacrificial ritual can
commence you just need to come with us
so it can begin the day of great Freedom
when you will Unleash Your Thousand-Year
reign of Madness upon the land I'm not
really into madness I'm more to
OverWatch SCP 2662 backs away from the
supplicants even as they come at him
with more and more grotesque offerings
cow tongues unidentifiable mushrooms one
woman tries to hand him a crying baby he
refuses each one but they are persistent
as he's swatting away jars of pickled
frogs a woman begins drawing a circle
around the room and what he hopes is red
paint but fears is something else
entirely um thank you for all these
gifts you have proven yourself as loyal
followers I'm going to stay here though
to uh spread the madness from here you
you you can all go home he tries to
shoot them out but they continue to
press closer thankfully his rescue
finally show goes up task force Town 9
swoops in at this point and begins
knocking out and administering amnestics
to all of the cultists they may not be
able to cure them of their mad devotion
but they can at least make sure the cult
forgets the location of the containment
unit at least for a little while they're
able to dispense with these particular
Intruders humanely but they may need to
use lethal Force for the next ones
that's always a possibility after the
cultists have been removed from the site
some maintenance staff are called in to
repair the damage to the wall where the
explosives knocked it in while they work
2662 goes over his newspaper one more
time making sure he didn't miss anything
attention to detail is an important
skill to have especially if one intends
to get the most out of their everyday
life he finds a few editorials he
neglected to read before and enjoys
finishing up the newspaper in its
entirety 400 p.m. after the task force
returns to their stations and the
maintenance crew has finished fixing the
wall SCP 2662 turns to one of his newest
Hobbies he attempted to hide this
Pursuit from the foundation at first but
they agreed to let him try it out as
long as he followed some safety
precautions so now at around 400 p.m.
every day SCP 2662 streams on his very
own twitch Channel he never uses
identifying information and keeps his
camera turned off the entire time L the
internet sees his tentacled face but he
does talk to the few viewers in his chat
via a microphone what's up it's good boy
2662 back to play some games for you
guys again hope you're all having a
killer day and thanks for tuning in
today I'm going to be checking out Apex
Legends for the very first time a lot of
you recommended this game to me so I'm
stoked to check it out as a small fan
Community watches SCP 2662 tries out the
popular MMO RPG and plays his way
through it for several hours one person
in the chat asks if he has ever heard of
the quote great tentacle Beast of Legend
but he makes sure to block them before
they give the rest of the chat any ideas
he doesn't want people to watch his
streams because he's some famous elder
god or something he wants to be liked
for who he is 700 p.m. every gamer needs
to break for some fuel and SCP 2662 is
no exception at around 700 he wraps up
his stream thanks all of his viewers and
subscribers and gets ready to have some
dinner he throws on another podcast this
time an actual play podcast following a
tabletop gaming campaign and digs into
to his last meal of the day like all of
his other meals it varies from day to
day but most of the time he goes with
his favorite pizza a big cheese pizza
delivered from a local pizza shop by a
delivery boy who has received more than
his fair share of amnestics and can
never remember why exactly this random
unmarked building seems so familiar
munching on his pizza and listening to
Tales of magic and Mayhem acted out by a
group of friends at a game table SCP
2662 can't help but feel just a little
Melancholy he's happy with what he has
of of course but he dreams of a normal
life the kind of life where he and his
friends could play games together or
record a podcast where he could share
this pizza with someone else but he
might not ever have that and it's
something that he has to accept he can
still choose to appreciate what he has
rather than mourn what he doesn't after
he's finished eating and the episode is
finished it's back to the normal grind
at the computer he turns on the Sims for
a little while constructing the kind of
normal life he'd like to fantasize about
sometimes but then one of his Sims burns
down the house while trying to make eggs
and he gives up on that particular
Endeavor to play some Minecraft 11:00
p.m. Some Nights the excitement keeps
SCP 2662 awake and playing his games
until the we hours of the morning
tonight however he finds himself
exhausted from an unexpectedly
action-packed day courtesy of those
cultists he Powers down the game turns
on his final podcast of the day a guided
meditation to wind him down for sleep
and climbs into bed tomorrow tomorrow
he'll get up and do it all again doing
his best to carve out a little bit of
Peace in a strange chaotic World maybe
tomorrow he'll just be left alone
allowing to be himself instead of what
everyone expects him to be he'll just
have to stick it out and see that's the
beauty of life after all tomorrow is
always a new day want to own an SCP of
your own go to SCP swag.com for premium
anomalous merchandise that's right it's
that time again we're recalibrating
rebooting and hitting restart on our
Infamous
anamatronic supercomput we've developed
to simulate improbable scenarios between
the SCP foundation's various anomalies
and any other characters from any other
Universe you could possibly imagine on
today's agenda what do you think would
happen if John Wick the notorious Hitman
highly trained in all forms of combat
was up against an enemy that won't go
down in a single shot an undead Menace
known as scps 008 well we're about to
hit the button and find out either by a
pure unpredictable instance of human
error or through the act of some Twisted
karmic fate the SCP Foundation had an
outbreak on their hands a sample of the
complex prion a virus known as SCP 008
had leaked the foundation had hoped to
keep the existence of the disease highly
classified even among its own Personnel
Their Fear had been that some hostile
force would attempt to synthesize or
even weaponize as CP 008 after all the
disease had a 100% rate of both
infection and lethality it killed
anything it came into contact with or at
least it killed them to begin with
before long everyone in the foundation
facility that had been exposed to the
leaking sample of SCP 8's already
infected victims was dead flu like
symptoms were followed swiftly by a coma
however the disease hijacked the bodies
of all those it had passed to
reactivating the the motor functions of
their corpses and turning them into well
you can already guess no one was safe
even the mobile task force on the scene
were soon infected with SCP 008 they had
been a squad of rookies and fresh face
new recruits sent in by the foundation
under the assumption that an outbreak of
this sort should have been easy to
contain it wasn't the entire facility
was soon overrun the bodies of
foundation researchers security officers
and MTF troops reanimated after for
their deaths now jostling around in
search of survivors to pass SCP 008 onto
that should hold them Dr alto clef
yelled locking the entrance to the
Watchtower tight H this really is
another fine mess clef his colleague Dr
gears replied in frustration our MTF
backup are all down we could be the last
two people on site and we're locked in a
tower with only one entry tell me what
the hell are we supposed to do now ah
we'll relax clef insisted don't worry
there's someone we can call to get us
out of this jam oh don't say I know a
guy gears sighed as his fellow
researcher gave a wide grin and reach
for his cell phone a few moments later
and only a matter of miles away another
phone started ringing its owner a man in
a dark all black tailored suit with a
shadowy shirt and tied to match reached
into his pocket and lifted his cell
phone to his ear good evening I
apologize for calling you at this hour
came the unmistakable voice of Sharon
the of the New York Continental Hotel
that's quite all right replied the
suited man we received the call asking
for your whereabouts sir a job the man
asked in a monotone voice indeed Sheron
replied UPF front I'm afraid not the
hotel's receptionist answered
sympathetically the contract is only in
exchange for payment upon completion the
man who made the call was very insistent
he said he will be in no position to pay
until the job is done but he asked for
you specifically and and told us he'd be
grateful for your assistance the man on
the end of the line sighed where oh
don't worry sir the friendly coners
replied we're sending a car for you at
that precise moment a yellow New York
Cab pulled up to the sidewalk best of
luck Mr Wick Sharon said before hanging
up the call straightening his suit the
infamous Hitman John Wick climbed into
the back of the taxi As It sped off
towards its destination arriving at a
complex Upstate far off the beaten track
johon examined his surroundings while
the car inched closer to the nearest
part of the facility his years of
training as an assassin under the
tutelage of Rus groma had given him an
instinctive spatial awareness one that
came in handy in his line of work but
even then John couldn't have predicted
that something would come leaping down
from above crashing through the Cab's
windshield the car's Hood buckled under
the impact fragments of glass spraying
everywhere as an arm cracked the front
window the thing snarled in and gurgled
like a wild animal as it reached for the
taxi driver gripping his arm it pulled
him by the wrist Biting Down causing him
to scream in intense pain meanwhile Jon
had already moved with lightning fast
reflexes and sprung out of the back seat
he hadn't had a chance to assess the
threat his instincts told him his best
option was put some distance between
himself and whatever had just attacked
the car then he'd be able to get a
better idea of what he was dealing with
the job description he'd been hired for
had been light on details Jon's mystery
employer only referred to it as a quote
cleanup operation sprinting towards the
facility Jon slammed the door behind him
he pulled off his belt from around his
waist and wrapped it tightly around the
door handles it would hold for now it
was only when he turned around that he
saw a few clustered groups of figures
shuffling around inside the building's
Atrium the nearest Gaggle were close
enough that it was easy for JN to make
out their pale skin sunken eyes and
cheeks the unnatural twitches and ertic
movements they were making as the
creatures turned to look back at him
zombies John Wick muttered under his
breath that's unexpected the nearby Trio
of SCP 008 infectees looked like they
were about to make a dash towards him so
JN moved fast he raced towards a nearby
Corridor hearing that the three zombies
were already chasing after him their
shambling footsteps had quickly become
an animalistic charge their limbs only
able to move after death thanks to the
virus that they were infected with
turning a corner John Wick took cover
his shoulder pressed to the wall he drew
his pistol from its holster underneath
his suit jacket and stood in a battle
ready stance the second he saw one of
the zombies faces appear around the
corner he raised his weapon and fired
swooping around one of his hiding places
to fire another two shots all three hit
Center Mass right through their chests
the noise would no doubt have drawn the
attention of the other SCP 008s in the
building but for now the three that had
been on his tail dropped to the floor
only to start getting back up again Jon
wasn't used to his Target standing to
their feet after he'd already fired at
them and the nearest of the zombies
staggered back to his level he lifted
his firearm again before his finger
could compress enough force on the
trigger though the undead Abomination
took a wild flailing swipe at him the
SCP 008 instance knocked the weapon out
of Jon's hand causing it to clatter to
the ground while it reared back its
other arm for a second strike catching
the blow John Wick displayed his
incredible reflexes and Mastery of
martial arts he delivered a series of
precise punches and chops deploying a
combination of Brazilian jiujitsu akido
and Krav Maga to try and knock the
snarling monster down with each hit he
was careful to avoid the zombie's mouth
having seen one bite the cab driver
earlier John had assessed that SCP 008
could be transmitted through biting and
he was correct exposure to mucous
membranes or bodily fluids of an
infected individual was what allowed the
virus to spread one of the other SCP 008
zombies that were still in the process
of climbing back up swiped Jon's legs
out from underneath him the master
assassin toppled over landing on his
back with the weight of the first
Monster still on top of him while the
second claw of this tapered suit pants
seconds before it could snap its teeth
down on his ankle John pulled back his
leg and shot it back out in a
devastating bicycle kick that sent the
second zombie reeling into the third
which was still trying to get back up
after its earlier gun shot but the first
of the creatures were still bearing down
on him mustering as much of his Peak
Physical strength as he needed John Wick
held the zombie at Bay blocking it with
one arm stopping it from getting close
enough to bite him his eyes started
around looking for something anything he
could use that was one of Jon's most
enviable and impressive skills one that
made him so renowned as a legend of the
Assassin world in the hands of John Wick
any ordinary everyday object could be a
Lethal Weapon reaching out with this
other hand Jon felt his fingertips brush
against something metal it was so close
just Out Of Reach on top of him the
zombie flailed its arms trying to claw
him lifting both legs in a fluid btic
motion John Wick kicked the creature off
of him crawling towards the nearby
object and grabbing it just as the
zombie started to approach again with
the swing in a loud metallic clang the
heavy fire extinguisher collided with
the SCP 008 infectees had the force of
the blow caused it to drop in an instant
Landing in a heap on the floor John
waited a second to see if it would get
back up again but it was still the other
two zombies suddenly dashed towards the
infamous Hitman only for their prey to
duck and weave effortlessly between
their aggressive clawing swipes bashing
his makeshift weapon against their heads
like a battering ram against a door all
three were down but the entire facility
was still crawling with a mass of the
reanimated monstrosities calmly Jon
smoothed his suit and straightened up
his shirt and tie walking with the fire
extinguisher in hand back down the
corridor towards the sound of more SCP
00008 zombies snarling they were next
the Baba Yaga would use anything he
found to take down each and every one of
them until not one was left standing it
didn't matter if all he had was a fire
extinguisher or one of the Fallen
security officer batons or even just a
tiny pencil nothing would make it out of
that facility alive
he just had to go for the head still
trapped in the Watchtower Dr clef and Dr
gears had long since grown irritated
with each other's company they had no
security feeds no way of knowing what
was going on within the overrun
Foundation facility for a while the pair
of researchers had been toying with the
idea of climbing out of a window and
scaling down the side of the tower but
giving up on that plan when they'd
realized they'd only be dropping back
into a horde of SCP 008 zombies a sudden
explosion erupted from one corner of the
complex causing gears and cleft to
direct their attention towards it from
their elevation they could see the
ground below was littered with the
bodies of the SCP 008 infectees rendered
lifeless once again by significant
cranial trauma in short something had
been bashing the zombies in the head or
someone the sound of a banging against
the locked Watchtower door startled both
Foundation scientists instantly they
thought that the zombies had made their
way up the steps and found the two
Searchers easy prey trapped in a cage
the heavy thud against the metal door
repeated then there was a pause
deafening tense silence filling the room
a polite knock came from the other side
of the Watchtower entrance cautiously
clef approached to unlock it standing in
the doorway as it opened was a single
figure panting with exhaustion but still
nowhere near beaten he looked out at
clef and gears from his dark hair a
Stern expression on his face neither one
of the researchers could believe that he
was still alive still uninfected but
then again he was the one and only John
Wick the Baba Yaga when you work for the
SCP Foundation One certainty is that
nothing no turn of events no scenario is
ever really unexpected no matter how
unlikely something may appear chances
are it usually happens and if it doesn't
happen here then in an infinite
Multiverse of Alternatives everything
that can possibly happen happen is
statistically likely to we've covered a
few of these alternate eventualities
before a number of which revolve around
the differing events in the long life of
one particular anomaly SCP 076-2 better
known as Abel in our home Universe much
like he is and many others Abel is
considered to be a near-perfect warrior
his body covered in tattoos of occult
symbols and demonic faces is capable of
with standing vast amounts of physical
damage AEL can easily take hits from the
most powerful Conventional Weapons
mankind has to offer and survive with
little more than a scratch what's more
he can draw an endless supply of black
bladed weapons from a tiny pocket
Dimension and on top of all of that even
in the event that he's bested in combat
ael's body will rapidly disintegrate
only to reform within a large Stone Cube
known as SCP 076-2
like most of us Abel has a number of
almost identical counterparts that exist
across the various worlds of the
Multiverse one of them once had the
opportunity to reconcile with his
brother Cain the man seemingly
responsible for Abel's endless life of
Bloodshed and once the two brothers had
made peace they could rest In Another
Universe AEL worked directly with the
SCP Foundation as part of a mobile task
force until they turned on him this
unfurled a chain of events so
cataclysmic that the entire World
suffered the consequences this alternate
able went on a war path against the
foundation ultimately using SCP 914 the
Clockworks to refine his destructive
anomalous abilities this allowed him to
unleash chaos slaughtering all of
humanity in an omnicide that wiped the
world clean of all other life leaving
Abel alone in a dead world and then
there was this version of The Immortal
Warrior far from the Clockworks enhanced
conqueror that is Al alternate universe
counterpart was this Abel had long since
been removed as a member of MTF Omega 7
and was gradually reconstituting his
body with an SCP
0761 his most recent defeat had enraged
the warrior and he had vowed to once
again be free although unbeknownst to
him what set this particular version of
Abel apart from his other variants was
the fact that he would soon encounter a
certain other anomaly something that
when wielded by SCP 07 6-2 had the
potential to completely Rob him of all
his centuries worth of fighting ability
and replace it with an embarrassment
that would last for centuries more but
first a quick history lesson much like
it had been in our universe this
particular anomalous object had been
recovered by the foundation after it
made its way into the hands of an
unwitting police officer the item in
question was SCP 572 a particularly
unique Katana unique in that was utterly
useless for fighting with and caused
more harm to the person wielding it than
whoever they were trying to use it
against in this universe the sword had
already changed hands a number of times
when Poli were called to the home of one
Clarence Clancy clerson he drew SCP 572
in defense and screamed at the officers
that he would quote take their heads and
with it their power the cops who had
been sent over to arrest Clancy for
violent and disorderly Behavior were
less than threatened to see their
suspect who was somewhat out of shape
coming at them with a weapon no sharper
than a butter knife after pacifying
Clancy with tasers and bean bag rounds
from a 12 gauge shotgun the police
retrieved SCP 572 and then it was
acquired by a foundation operative this
all played out almost the exact same way
in our universe however in this version
of events there was one key difference
as previously mentioned SCP 572 was an
unremarkable sword but it had something
of a story passed passing from one
unfortunate user to the next and just as
it was recovered from Clancy's house and
ended up in Foundation hands one of
those former owners had just been about
to reclaim the fabled weapon for himself
meanwhile back in this containment
chamber deep under the ocean still
trapped in the stone Cube he reanimated
within Abel was lost in a dream to any
other person falling asleep to see
subconscious visions of so much Carnage
would be horrifying they would call him
a nightmare but to Abel this might have
been one of the sweetest dreams that he
had ever experienced all around him was
a world on fire having returned to life
once again Abel at last vested his
captors at the SCP Foundation in his
dream he traveled the world visiting
every Foundation facility one by one and
reducing them to Rubble without leaving
a single Survivor then once the work was
done he turned his barbarism towards the
wider world and began slaughtering
Humanity in droves perhaps some distant
Cosmic Echo had reached out across the
Multiverse a fragment of the life of a
more refined version of himself had
slipped into Abel's subconsciousness
making him dream that he too was the
omnicidal Conqueror that his other self
was seeing such Devastation in his own
wake made this version of Abel eager to
wake up to revive once more and set
about making this delightful dream of
Destruction a deadly reality it was
while Abel was dreaming picturing
himself cutting down all who dared
oppose him that something strange seemed
to happen he had a visitor not a visitor
to his containment chamber mind you
there was no one beyond the confines of
SCP 0761 except the security team that
normally kept the stone Cube under arm
surveillance no this visitor appeared
somewhere else inside Abel's mind
approaching him as he slept within the
warrior slumbering fantasy he was
climbing up a mountain of skulls after
having slaughtered Millions if not
billions already but as he reached the
top of the pile of bones and looked out
over the horizon Abel could see that the
world Beyond was still living there were
just as many people alive perhaps even
more that he'd already killed his work
was not yet done in fact it seemed that
despite all the lives The Immortal
madman had already claimed he had barely
even begun oh AEL a voice tutted did you
really think you could do it alone even
though this was a dream Abel could feel
the presence of another he pulled one of
his obsidian edged weapons from thin air
and swiped in the direction The Voice
had come from hitting nothing the blade
in his hand seemed to change its dark
metal transforming from solid to liquid
coming apart in his hands ael's sword
melted like candle wax under a hot flame
reduced to nothing in seconds you can't
do it the voice whispered you aren't
strong enough but I can help with that
pulling out another weapon a two-handed
axe this time Abel looked around him
trying to locate the source of the
taunting noise only a coward relies on
cheap tricks and Illusions he growled
angrily show yourself come forward and
be slain are you a worthy opponent are
you worth your time are you the voice
justed we shall see Abel yelled behind
him a cloak figure silently appeared
they looked to be adorned in a robe that
whipped in the biting cold wind yet
their garments weren't made of any
fabric instead they wore a robe made out
of pure Shadow their clothes and body
comprised of the same thing though they
lacked any tangible solid matter it
didn't stop Abel from spinning around
swinging his heavy axe in the figure's
direction before the blade of the weapon
was even halfway through the air it had
already started to become liquid just
like the swords had earlier by the time
it came down to strike at the shadowy
visitor what had once been an axe was
just a flick of melted black metal
passing through the intangible Spectre
as Abel found himself once again unarmed
speak Craton he demanded never one to
back away from a fight even when his
weapons were seemingly failing him tell
me who you are I would like to know my
adversary's name before I end your
worthless life I am not here to fight
you the figure replied calmly I'm here
to offer you the key to your victory
able what key the warrior sneered what
could you possibly give me exactly what
you need to finish it the shadow replied
drawing something from a sheath on its
belt and holding it aoft a weapon that
will allow you to become the Conqueror
you long to be Abel looked at the object
in the figure's outstretched hand a
katana or at least the shadowy vestage
of one a sword he sneered what use do I
have for a sword I can conjure all the
blades I needed will to demonstrate able
pulled one of his own black blades but
yet again it began to melt away your
weapons have served you well but they
are disposable the shadow explained a
true warrior deserves a sword worthy of
his fighting prowess I have killed
scores of men throughout the ages The
Immortal Warrior retorted and I never
needed any special sword to do that and
that is why no matter how many you kill
you will always always be beaten in his
dream Abel paused a moment looking at
the katana and considering then he
reached his hand out to grip the shadowy
hilt in that same Split Second SCP 076-2
awoke once again from his Slumber and
broke free of the stone Cube encasing
him as he killed his way through the
foundation Personnel in the facility
housing SCP
0761 Abel had only one thought in his
mind he needed that sword you see what
the immortal Maniac was fortunately
totally unaware of was the interesting
effect SCP 572 could have on people as
well as being a totally useless sword
anyone who picked it up will instantly
believe the katana of apparent
invincibility to be an all powerful
weapon of ancient legend despite the
sword being crudely made blunt and
generally unfit for any use the wielder
will maintain the belief that it not
only has perfect balance and cutting
power but that the sword has also imbued
them with unparalleled strength strength
and invincibility to damage and now
either through the sword itself
extending this Cognito hazardous
influence into ael's dream or by the
interference of some unknown trickery
one of the most dangerous and anomalous
killers in the world was making a beine
straight for SCP 572 and he wasn't the
only one either at a previous point in
time a man by the name of Zach had
purchased SCP 572 on eBay but it was far
more than just an odity to him he wasn't
looking to start a sword collection as a
child he had been obsessed with comic
book superheroes and when Zach bought
that Katana he intended to use the blade
to dispense vigilante justice against
those who prayed on the innocent and
even before he held it in his hands Zack
2 felt the anomalous pull of the katana
knowing in his heart it was the perfect
weapon to transform him into a hero of
course he had quickly been disproven
when on his first night of crime
fighting Zack had been hit by a midsize
sedan in a multi-story parking lot and
suffered a concussion sent to the
hospital and then charged with attempted
assault Zach had long since lost any and
all interest in ever Dawning his costume
comprised of hockey pads and a ski mask
or picking up the sword ever again but
as time had gone on that old familiar
pole had started to gnaw at Zach urging
him to get back in the superhero game
forgetting how poorly that had worked
out for him last time one problem still
stood in his way though he needed his
trusty sword back of course in the time
since he'd hung up his hero outfit
glancy had gotten his hands on SCP 572
and then right before Zach could steal
it back the foundation had taken it it
had taken him months of preparation he'd
sneakily made dealings with a janitor
that worked at one of the foundation's
sites Zach had bribed the man a lot of
money and exchanged for his key card and
uniform even having to take out a second
mortgage on his apartment to meet the
frankly extortionate amount the janitor
asked for but it would be worth the cost
Zach told himself if it reunited him
with his trusty Katana then it would be
worth it only then would he once again
be a full hero shuffling through the
facility Zach dragged a mop over the
floor leaving a sign to warn the
slippery Hazard he whistled to himself
trying to act as casually as possible
not realizing that he was slightly
overselling it once he was certain the
coast was clear he made his move SCP 572
was locked in a secure deposit box
within site 19's high value item storage
facility right where he had been
cleaning he began searching through the
various anomalous Oddities kept there
until he saw it the Box containing his
coveted sword all his effort in
infiltrating the foundation had finally
paid off it was all leading to this his
comeback in crime fighting it was at
this precise moment that Abel came
bursting through a nearby door
completely befuddled Zach quickly found
him himself thrown to one side by the
much stronger man out of my way weakling
Abel roared before turning to face the
deposit box holding SCP 572 gripping the
Box Abel used his superhuman strength to
tear it open as though the container was
made from cardboard there it was stored
safely within was the weapon he had been
seeking the same all powerful sword from
his vision at last he declared reaching
for the hilt this sword belongs to me
the second that Abel hoisted it into the
air he felt a human weight Dash towards
him only to shrug it off as it made
impact Zach tumbled to the floor winded
as Abel barely flinched at the attempted
tackle you fool he roared you dare come
at me you'll be the first to fall to my
new Blade the first of this pathetic
world of unworthy opponents to die in my
Conquest Zach frighteningly raised his
arms in an attempt to Shield himself
when abble raised the sword menacingly
above his head the Mortal man knew what
the sword was capable of or so he
thought as Abel brought the blade
swiping downwards its true
ineffectiveness as a melee weapon was on
fold display SCP 572 is dull poorly
balanced blade barely grazed Zach's arms
as he protected his face in fact beyond
the initial SWAT it barely hurt I I
don't understand Abel stammered looking
at the katana in confusion this is meant
to be a warrior blade a weapon of
Champions and conquerors yeah that's
what I was thinking Zach replied also
suffering from SCP 572 Cognito hazardous
effect he'd fully expected to die a
second ago slain by the very weapon he
had been hoping to reclaim still maybe
it's just because it's your first go I
could show you how to silence I will not
fall for that Abel interrupted let me
see here maybe the angle was off or how
about I use both hands here let me just
once again Abel hoisted the weapon this
time with both hands tightly gripping
the blade intending to bring it slashing
down in a big swing like a Woodsman
cleaving a log in two unfortunately as
he raised the sword the blade caught and
exposed light fixture above Sparks burst
from the ceiling as an electrical
current shot through the metal and gave
Abel a nasty shock oh God what is the
meaning of this he shouted in
frustration I've been alive for
centuries killed thousands upon
thousands of men since the dawn of
civilization why can't I use this sword
well performance issues for a guy your
age hardly enough uncommon problem Zach
joked both turned at the sound of a door
kicked open the clump of heavy boots on
the ground as a foundation security team
burst in SCP 076-2 drop your weapons in
the commander stopped mid shout wait
that's not one of his regular swords is
it sir um that's uh one of the officers
paused inside I think that's SCP
572 attack me Abel yelled at the
foundation officers pointing the dull
tip of the katana at them if you dare
for now I will the greatest blade known
to the universe you will all fall in a
single stroke of my new weapon and once
you have fallen so shall the world SCP
076-2 able look just put the thing down
the commander urged trust me you you'll
thank
yourself you pathetic fools are so
afraid of the chaos I will unleash the
warrior declared such unworthy opponents
okay I've seen enough the security
Commander sighed deadly force authorized
light them up boys on the Commander's
signal a hail of gunfire erupted bullets
raining down on able he slashed SCP 572
through the air certain that what he
thought was a mighty sword could easily
cut through the oncoming bullets of
course that may have been true if SCP
572 is only real power was not having
any power at all each shot struck ael's
Center Mass barely damaging him given
his body's natural resilience to harm
particularly from such Small Arms fire
although he didn't find it any less
annoying that he couldn't seem to
properly wield his new Katana or are you
kidding me he huffed to himself what is
with me today can't get the hang of this
thing come on me but Ste a sword the
weapon that will allow me to conquer
this whole world but if I can just get
the swing right calmly knowing that the
weapon itself posed no threat even in
the hands of an immortal mass murderer
the security team moved in to apprehend
AEL before they could take the from his
hands he dashed towards them swiping the
sword back and forth hoping to at least
hit someone to get the ball rolling on
his omnicidal Rampage instead thanks to
the influence of SCP 572 he
miscalculated took a wrong step and
slipped over on a patch of freshly moed
tile Landing in a heap next to a wet
floor sign the security Team all winced
feeling the secondhand embarrassment
practically radiating off of AEL as the
ancient anomalous Warrior lay on the
floor after after a spectacular fall
then one by one they all burst out into
uncontrollable fits of laughter but
while they were distracted they were
completely oblivious to Zach who emerged
from his hiding place and picked SCP 572
up off the floor he breathed toide
relief reunited with his prized weapon
having forgotten the severe injury it
caused him last time you Abel wheezed
still lying in a puddle of mop water who
are you Zach gave a slight smile zipping
the janitor's overalls he had on to
reveal a set of hockey pads underneath
he slipped a ski mask over his face
before turning back to Abel and replying
in his most epic voice I'm captain
Katana unfortunately his return to crime
fighting would be as shortlived as ael's
own turn with SCP 572 as Captain Katana
found himself hit by a bus on his way
home after trying to use the katana of
apparent invincibility to cut said bus
in half down the middle and failing in a
rather painful fashion the thin pale
humanoid anomaly had just found itself
in Minecraft of all places the all two
familiar whale of emergency alarms rang
out through the corridors of the
foundation facility it had happened
again another containment breach of
course the on-site Personnel were more
than familiar with the protocols for a
situation like this so well versed in
what to do during an emergency that it
had become second nature whether they
were research staff evacuating for their
own safety or security teams moving in
to recapture the escaped anomaly and get
the situation under control everyone was
moving like they had been programmed
muscle memory taking over the loose
anomaly was none other than scp096 all
Foundation Personnel were alerted and
reminded not to look directly at the
creature there was just one problem they
couldn't look even if they'd ignored
their ordered to try nobody could
because the shy guy was nowhere to be
found well nowhere in in the real world
at least this whole situation bizarre
even by Foundation standards had all
started with an experiment involving a
member of the Disposable d-class
Personnel yet another dangerous convict
serving one of several life sentences
now being used as an Expendable human
lab rat for the foundation's often
Sinister purposes the experiment in
question was an attempt to further test
the limitation of scp096
abilities by now the foundation had done
extensive Research into the creature
known as the shy guy they knew its
particular brand of anomalous qualities
were triggered when anyone looked
directly at it being observed would
instantaneously send scp096 into an
uncontrollable rage State causing it to
pursue its Observer until they were no
longer standing scp096 was known to be
able to travel at speed so relentless it
was pretty much impossible to stop one
moment it was sobbing and screeching in
its cell having just been observed and
minutes later the wide jawed long limed
monster was standing behind whoever had
seen it making its screaming face the
image its victim took to the Grave with
them Foundation researchers knew that
scp-096's rage State could be triggered
by as little as someone seeing the
slightest hint of a creature even if the
shy guy had been captured as a tiny
Speck in the background of a photograph
it would come after anyone whose eyes so
much as glanced over that Speck it also
didn't matter how far away the Observer
was scp096 could not be outrun it could
track down anyone wherever they were in
the world but what if a person who had
observed the shy guy was no longer in
the world the experiment had taken a lot
of trial and error after all digitizing
a human being and transforming their
entire Consciousness into code was no
easy task but the foundation wasn't
above breaking more than a few eggs to
make an omelet especially when those
eggs were the brains of a few d-class
personnel
actually the first test subjects turned
out more scrambled or fried certainly
overdone given the amount of smoke
coming from their ears but eventually
the research team had perfected the
device they dubbed the neural harness a
headset that could translate a person's
mind into pure digital code their
Consciousness would be extracted from
their body leaving their physical form
an empty shell while a digital copy of
them was able to Traverse the local
on-site computer network of course the
foundation wasn't about to let a
digitized d-class run a muuk with their
systems so their coding experts wrote a
number of specialized parameters into
their successful test subject now the
digital d-class could be programmed to
follow the foundation's directive from
his perspective it was like he was
floating through cyberspace towards the
system that the foundation had directed
him to a surveillance camera inside
scp096 cell that usually remained
inactive but not today the camera
blinked to life as soon as the class's
code-based Consciousness reached it and
through it he was able to observe SC
scp096 sitting against the far wall of
its containment chamber gently
whimpering and walking back and forth
that is until the creature felt that
same familiar sensation of being watched
it stood up enraged wailing
uncontrollably as the d-class watched
from within the camera then a split
second later scp096 appeared to Blink
out of existence it hadn't work the
experiment had failed and the digital
d-class began to panic before the
foundation coders could stop him he
frantically scoured the local network
for anything some kind of Escape Route
back into the real world maybe he
thought if he could get back into his
body it wouldn't count technically his
digital self was separate from his
physical form so he might get out of SCP
96's clutches on a technicality but it
was impossible his body was already
burned out by the neural harness there
was no way for the d-class to transfer
himself back there was only one option
left hide and as it turned out someone
had forgotten to uninstall a certain
building game from a computer in one of
the foundation doctor's offices the DCL
classes digitized mind zapped him into
Minecraft from his point of view it was
like he existed within the game itself
he did a computerized equivalent of
breathing a sigh of relief only to take
back all those ones and zeros in a
horrified gasp as he noticed a tall wiry
framed figure before him it hadn't
worked scp096 had still managed to
follow him into Minecraft even in a
world of computer code the shy guy was
able to dispatch its digital Observer
quite easily and what had once been a
living human mind in the form of binary
code was quickly deleted but that's when
scp096 started to take notice of its
surroundings but the most recent person
to see it gone it had the chance to
actually take in where it was the bright
rays of warm light coming down from a
cube-shaped sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around constructed
entirely from cubes it fascinated scp096
instilling a kind of childlike Wonder in
the shy guy the likes of which it hadn't
experienced since well since it couldn't
remember when rather than leaving
instantly reappearing in its containment
chamber scp096 made the conscious
decision to start exploring there was a
mountainous biome surrounding scp096
Stony spires reaching up towards a clear
sky with a waterfall cascading its way
down the nearest of them at the foot of
the mountains was the opening of a cave
which the shy guy found itself wandering
towards the light from the sun while a
pleasant and welcoming change to the
surroundings it was used to was a little
harsh on scp096 is sunken eyes so
instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves not
unlike the usual darkness of its
containment chamber back at the
foundation Traverse cing through long
winding corridors of stone as CP 096
found itself having to bend down to
avoid hitting its head on the Cave's low
ceiling obviously this formation of
Rocky blocks had informed with someone
of the shy guys's height in mind there
was a low Warm Glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer
despite the stone walls around it
feeling like a tighter confinement than
its cell approaching the source of the
light scp096 was relieved that the cave
opened out into a more spacious area the
cramped tunnel giving way to an
expansive chamber that lay within the
heart of the mountain the warm orangey
glow that had been coming from a flowing
stream of boiling hot lava that seemed
to trickle down from somewhere above
creating a deadly fiery pool directly in
the Shy Guy's path but just before it
could turn back and leave the cave
through the way he came scp096 sensed
that familiar feeling of something
observing him across the lava pool on
the other side was a creature comprised
of a green Cube for a head with a long
armless cuboid body and four cubed feet
if it had been present in the real world
it might have been made out of leaves
like a living shrub it was staring
directly at the shy guy from across the
lava only for this strange newcomer to
disappear a moment later the creeper
hissed before it realized that scp096
had leaped up behind it to land a fatal
blow but little did the infamously
anxious anomaly realize that the
sentient shrub wasn't done there was a
colossal boom that caused scp096 to
stagger backwards whimpering at the
sudden loud explosion and the pain that
had accompanied it the creeper had blown
itself to Pieces but in doing so had
left a lasting injury that caused scp096
considerable discomfort as it began
limping towards the cave that led out
the opposite side of the mountain
despite its injury the shy guy was still
able to move with relative ease and the
further it went the more it seemed to
gradually heal however it was as it
stepped out once more into the sunlight
that the creature realized just how
hungry it was back in the real world it
hadn't eaten for several hours and
surprisingly even while accidentally
stuck in digitized form the hunger
mechanics of Minecraft were having an
effect on scp096 the shy guy started
searching around for anything that could
prove to satiate its hunger there was a
Grove of trees not far so as P 096
lumbered to take a closer look it
couldn't be certain but it felt there
was at least a slim chance that there
were apples growing amongst the leaves
but even at the anomaly's own elongated
height it couldn't simply reach up to
pick them however it was while swiping
its arms up at the tree that the shy guy
swung its Fist and knocked at the tree
trunk to the creature's surprise it was
able to chip away at the wood with its
hands punching at the tree until the
trunk had been reduced to a collection
of wooden blocks that the shy guy was
was able to collect and sure enough some
red apples dropped from the leaves above
enough to quell the hunger that SC
scp096 was feeling at least for the time
being nearby something was moving
through the trees it was yet to lock
eyes on scp096 but the second it did the
mob would surely have sealed its own
fate as it moved around minding its own
business the tall figure overheard the
sounds of the shy guy eating and its
attention was drawn to where the
creature was standing enjoying an apple
sensing that it had been seen as CP 096
turned and locked eyes with the entity
it was perhaps the only other being in
Minecraft that was a similar height and
stature to the anomaly itself in fact
the pair were strikingly similar before
scp096 could carry out its usual method
of attack the Enderman suddenly
teleported out of view but it was too
late now both it and the shy guy had
looked at the other's face both had been
provoked and were compelled to react in
exactly the same way
just as scp096 entered its rage State
the Enderman 2 opened its mouth and
began to shake making loud lengthy
sounds not to similar to the Shy Guy's
own angered screams but something
profoundly strange happened next scp096
and the Enderman kept attempting to
pursue one another appearing in a new
location within the Minecraft world
neither one getting close enough to the
other they' teleport only for the other
to teleport away the moment they saw
each other each trying to catch one
another but always staying one step
behind this rapid Chase almost became a
strange ongoing sort of teleporting
dance between SCP 096 and the Enderman
at first the shy guy had been compelled
to attack the Enderman like it was with
any who looked directly at it but as
they appeared and disappeared from place
to place the creature started to feel an
odd kinship with this shadowy fellow it
was so used to being frightened and
alone to its overwhelming feelings of
insecurity and self-loathing that the
Simplicity of just traversing the open
world with a creature very alike itself
in many ways it had all come as a
welcome change scp096 found it
therapeutic even and before long was
following the Enderman not out of any
intention to do it harm but just to feel
for a little while like it had a friend
just a little bit longer as CP 096
thought welcoming the enjoyment it felt
playing this game of Minecraft there
weren't a few rumors after the break of
day came Whispers that were passed on
from the lips of traiter Caravans as
they traveled from settlement to
settlement not many people would have
believed it way back then it sounded
just like a legend out of an old western
too good to be true a shadowy stranger
wandering the Wasteland writing wrongs
wherever he finds them then when the
job's done and innocent people are safe
once more he walks off into the Horizon
without asking for so much as a thank
you like we said folks would have a hard
time believing such a fanciful tale of
course that was before the sun started
shining an anomalous light over the
world nowadays people might believe
anything the earliest days of this
strange New World proved to be a
learning experience for SCP
4494 otherwise known as the Spectre he
was the physical embodiment of the very
notion of fighting crime where ever
Injustice arose he would appear to
Vanquish those that prayed on the
innocent while he usually manifested at
night he never used to have any trouble
appearing in the daytime too in the form
of a shadowy figure wearing a wide
brimmed hat and a long flowing coat that
he could alter the length of for added
dramatic flourish the spectre's form
absorbed almost all the light from the
visible spectrum but after day broke the
rules seemed to have changed one day the
Spectre had emerged to find the sunlight
had become unbearable where he had once
been a void of any and all light he was
now finding it impossible to manifest
during daylight the moment that the
unrelenting light from the sun made
contact with him SCP 4494 would
dissipate yet he kept reappearing at
night it was like he was being pulled
back into existence and was only able to
REM manifest in the Moonlight despite it
being a reflection of the anomalous
sunlight that was seemingly enough to
negate the effects it had of preventing
V ing SCP 4494 from reappearing the same
could not be said for any humans caught
in the light though a far worse fate
awaited them even with much of mankind
deformed into creatures that resembled
melted wax there were still pockets of
survivors and where there were human
beings there would be subex that wanted
to harm or exploit their fellow man the
world might have no governing bodies
anymore no Law and Order but the Spectre
has had realized that even in a lawless
World his work was not done as long as
there were survivors of the break of day
they still would need saving not just
from the flushy hordes of SCP 001 daa
roaming the wastes but saving from each
other striding through the remains of
the old world in the dead of night his
long cloak billowed out behind him its
shadow almost seemed to blend with the
darkness that surrounded the Spectre but
on the horizon there was a sight he
didn't often see these days light not
coming from the sun above nor the moon
but instead it lay ahead of him a fire
glowing not too far away as he wandered
closer Like An Outlaw striding into town
SCP 4494 was presented with the ruins of
a small settlement around him Shacks
burned their boarded up Windows broken
to allow the curs sunlight in everyone
that was still alive normally kept
themselves wrapped up head to toe to
block out the Sun but there were clothes
and protective goggles strewn all around
a larger pile of garments fueling a
bonfire SCP 4494 had witnessed the SCP
001 creatures attacking humans dragging
them out into the light to be
transformed into more anomalous
Abominations but what had happened here
didn't seem to be the work of those
creatures the specters suspicion were
confirmed when he approached the Town
Square to find a group of people who had
all been melted into a flushy Mass the
instance of SCP 001 daa paid the crime
fighter little mind it couldn't move
very far the few vaguely human shapes
that protruded out of it looked like
they were Tethered to poles in the
middle of the settlement it didn't take
much longer for SCP 4494 to figure out
what had happened here someone had
ransacked the settlement for some
unknown reason maybe they wanted
something maybe they were opportunists
just looking to take advantage of this
new post-apocalyptic world or perhaps
they wanted to be cruel to these
settlers they had broken the barricades
over the windows that blocked out the
sunlight they had trashed the ramshackle
homesteads that these innocent settlers
had been residing in as SCP 4494 looked
further there looked to have been
looting too food and water medical
supplies and ammunition not anything of
use to be found all that was left was
what these Raiders hadn't any need for
but as if all that had hadn't been
enough as if robbing the settlers For
What Little livelihood they had left
wasn't enough cruelty the bandits had
tethered the survivors to poles in the
center of town they had taken away their
protective gear and left them at the
mercy of the elements and as the sun had
crept higher into the sky and bathed the
captive settlers in its unforgiving
light they had melted into an SCP 001 D
creature turning away from the town the
Spectre did his best to quell his rage
he wandered in the direction of the next
settlement something was drawing him
there he could feel the pull of the
wrong doers that had left this Carnage
in their wake he would find them and
they would pay for what they had done
there was nothing he could do for their
last victims they had already been
turned by the sunlight but if anyone
could save the next group of survivors
it was him as the wind howled the
shadowy figures cloaked flapped in the
breeze the next settlement looks similar
to the the last although still intact
Shacks built from sheets of corrugated
iron and other scrap metal all welded
together so that not even as little as a
tiny beam of sunlight could bleed
through as he stepped toward the
boundary of the settlement a muzzle
flashed accompanied by the deafening
echo of a gunshot that reverberated all
around someone had tried to shoot at the
Spectre narrowly missing the bullet
whizzed past his head not that it would
have harmed him anyway fear not he
declared you can hold your fire I mean
you no harm you aren't with the slivers
a voice called in the nightly dark if
you mean the evildoers that left that
last settlement over a smoldering ruin
then no I'm not the Spectre replied
hearing this he spotted movement on one
of the Shack's rooftops a sharpshooter
carrying a worn old rifle stood up
covered in layers of protection from the
transformative effects of the Sun's
light reflected off the moon Well you
aren't dressed like they are give you
that the Sharpshooter called can barely
make you out wearing all those dark
clothes Mister but if you're looking at
trade I'm afraid your timing couldn't be
much worse tell me replied the Spectre
bluntly the criminals that terrorized
the other settlement they've been here
too yes sir the man answered said they'd
be back tonight too I've come to help to
do away with those that would inflict
Justice on the innocent SCP 4494
explained in his typically dramatic
Cadence you call them slivers yes
well they call themselves that the
Sharpshooter said on account of their
choice and outfits they look ridiculous
but they've covered their protective
clothing and slivers of metal and glass
that way they're not only protected from
light but their clothes reflected back
at other people too dly villains taking
advantage of what has befallen the Sun
the Spectre cursed the bandits why are
they yet to pillage Your settlement you
said they intended to return well that's
what they threatened earlier a lot of
them have been ransacking any settlement
they can't shake down they showed up
here in their stupid sparkling outfits
and demanded we hand over a half of all
of our food water and antibiotics they
call it their Sunshine taxs according to
them if we didn't meet their demands
they'd destroy the town we didn't know
to take them seriously until we saw the
fire over there on the horizon for a
moment the Spectre fell silent his cloak
had slowed waving gently now the winds
had died down but in contrast his anger
had never been higher who are you anyway
Mister the Sharpshooter asked never got
your name my name is the Spectre a name
these vagabonds will soon know well for
tonight they will pay the price for
their crimes no offense Mr um Mr Spectre
but look around world's gone to hell
ain't no justice anymore what price are
you expecting to make them pay simple
SCP 4494 answered the prices they now
have to face me an hour later the
settlement was quiet the Sharpshooter
was still at his post scanning the area
nearby for signs of mov
sure enough he spotted something a group
of figures approaching the Moonlight
glinting off their metallic outfits
revealing their position as they drew
closer and closer to the makeshift town
the slivers were coming but there would
be something else waiting for them when
they made their way into the settlement
the other settlers were awake despite
how late it was wearing their protective
layers and peeking through cracked doors
only to slam them shut as the glimmering
gang crossed the threshold into their
ramshackle home the the slivers whooped
and Jered brandishing weapons and
threatening the settlers to show
themselves before the bandits would
break into their shacks and do to them
what they' done to their neighbors at
the other town but as one of the slivers
approached the door of a shack and began
pounding his boot against the metal door
something reached out of the shadows and
grabbed him in fact it wasn't coming
from the Shadows it was the Shadows this
shrouded in darkness struck the
remorseless Raider even with the
protective layers covering his face the
sliver could feel himself being bruised
by the beating the Spectre struck once
more knocking the wrongdoer unconscious
and wrenching the reflective metals from
his outfit shattering them underfoot the
other slivers panicked one drawing a
handgun and firing the shots were
useless all they did was illuminate the
silhouette of a dark cloaked figure
walking closer and closer ready to make
them suffer for their crimes it was dusk
by the time the Spectre had beaten the
group of Bandits stripping them of their
distinctive reflective pieces each one
of the slivers had been beaten into
submission suffering broken ribs black
eyes and missing teeth with the danger
over the Sharpshooter and the other
settlers had emerged from their hiding
places all eager to weigh in on how best
to punish the bandits many yelled that
they should be strung up without their
protective gear so that the sun melted
them into an SCP 001 D but the Spectre
interjected urging the settlers not to
sink to the level of the criminals they
had been harassed by instead he turned
to the defeated slivers turn over half
of your food water and medical supplies
to these people SCP 4494 demanded in a
frighteningly calm voice then leave walk
into these wastes and don't come back
the slivers agreed and fled running as
fast as they could away from the town
why'd you let them go the Sharpshooter
asked these are uncertain times the
Spectre replied noticing the sun was
creeping Over the Horizon it'd be time
for him to go soon in the face of
hardship it can be easy to lose our way
justice has always been blind not
blinded by the sunlight But Blind to
prevent bias ah the slivers might come
back though the man said adding if they
can even survive with what you left them
maybe they'll live out there ascp 4494
responded then again perhaps not but
they have a chance
that is Justice in a time without law
it's the best we can offer and if they
carry on raiding folks if they harm
others if they want to waste the chance
they've been given then that is their
choice but they know if they refuse to
change then they will answer to the
Spectre with that the shadowy crime
fighter walked away from the settlement
the unforgiving light of the sun made
him fade as he sauntered off like an old
Gunslinger but he would be B back as
long as people needed saving he would
always be back scp096 the shy guy woke
up in an unfamiliar room without a
thought in its head however one thing
quickly occurred to it this was not its
containment chamber no the solid steel
Cube that had kept it locked up for
decades now didn't have a front desk or
walls covered in strange childlike
murals or tin party music playing over
old speakers wherever scp096 had found
itself it certainly wasn't the place it
had come to call home if it could read
it would have registered the words
behind the front desk painted onto the
wall ban Ban's kindergarten where Joy
Comes Alive little did 096 know
something really did come to life here
at band band's kindergarten but it
definitely wasn't Joy scp096 was
typically used to a much more in fine
space so presented with so much strange
Freedom its natural instinct was to
wander around whimpering quietly to
itself this place was certainly peculiar
with multiple large reinforced doors
each one having a large red button fixed
to the wall above them a strange green
creature was painted on the wall with an
affixed speech bubble that read jumbo
Josh says eat fruits and vegetables if
you want to be strong like me though 096
paid no mind to such things this place
looked like an SCP Foundation
containment facility mixed with an
offbrand
chuckecheese and some tiny part of the
Shy Guy's dim and dismal brain wanted to
see more of it what other Secrets could
it hold the shy guy pressed one of the
big red buttons causing the doors to
open underneath it there was a faint
sound of childish laughter somewhere
down the distant Hall how had it ever
found its way into such a strange place
the deeper the shy guy wandered the more
strange murals it saw on the wall there
was one for a large orange cartoon
jellyfish with one staring eye where the
speech bubble readed Stinger Flynn says
having many arms allows me to help a lot
of people then a squat blue gorilla
likee creature with sharp lower teeth
had a speech bubble that read Captain
fiddles says ugaa Booga ooga a white
feminine catlike creature had the speech
bubble bambolina says kindness is free
so sprink it everywhere a misshapen pink
bird creature had the speech bubble Opa
bird says laughter is the best medicine
so make sure to smile and of course most
importantly of all presiding over the
creativity room was a mural of a
grinning red creature wearing a pair of
party hats on its head like horns his
speech bubble read ban ban says sharing
is caring your pancreas is mine a
whiteboard not far from this mural had
the words run for your lives hastily
scrawled onto it to anyone but the shy
guy who had no point of reference this
was clearly not a normal kindergarten as
the shy guy passed into the hallway
slowly lumbering along it suddenly felt
an intense Spike of burning pain right
through its forehead Rising like a fever
pitch the shy guy subdued whimpers
quickly escalated into horrifying whales
of animalistic rage this could only mean
one thing somewhere something had made
the terrible mistake of gazing at the
shy guy's face in fact not 10 ft away
the unfortunate opela bird had made that
very mistake it typically peaked out
from behind one of the hallways pillars
to get a good look at any potential
Intruders or new prey wandering into its
midst but this time the beastly Bird's
curiosity had taken it from Predator to
prey itself though it wouldn't realize
this until it was already too late as
the mutant bird creature scattered back
back into the cavernous Hall filled with
plastic trees and an underwhelming play
area the shy guy came Galloping after it
on all fours roaring with Fury the opala
bird was shocked to see the creature
giving chase this doesn't make sense I
meant to chase you you're not meant to
chase me but things are rarely fair when
it comes to the shy guy arguably one of
the most dangerous uclid class creatures
ever kept in Foundation containment the
opala bird flapped desperately towards
the boarded escape hatch but the shy guy
was so much faster he grabbed hold of
the bird gripping it in its iron
clutches and began to stretch open its
bottom jaw with a blood curdling Roar
we'll spare you the details of what
happened next but suffice to say little
more than a handful of feathers were
left after finishing off the opala bird
the shy guy reverted from Rage back to
pitiful sadness this place was no better
than the SCP Foundation there were still
creatures here to look at its face and
drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress it was horrible the
shy guy needed to find a way to hide
himself away again so he decided to tear
away the planks covering up the escape
hatch and L down the narrow Hall in
there the shy guy actually found
something to its liking two platforms
one on either side of the room with what
seemed to be a deep dark casm between
the two for most there was an electrical
lift system for carrying them between
the platforms but the shy guy had no
interest in the platforms he only sought
the darkness below where nobody could
see his face that would suit him just
fine the shy guy jumped over the
guardrail and plummeted down below into
the dark feeling the air against its
cold gray skin as it fell felt wonderful
it dared to think that it might even
find solace in this deep dark place but
as soon as he hid something solid some
kind of metal lift system alarms went
off and flashing red light soon made
everything down there in the darkness
visible to be exposed like this while it
thought it was hidden was the dreaded
shy gu's worst nightmare little did he
know he would soon become the worst
nightmare of a number of other beasts as
the shy guy crawled off the metal
platform hoping that perhaps it could
find another place to hide down here its
hands and feet splashed into shallow
water had something sprung a leak down
here the shy guy began wandering the
half dark as the water of this flooded
sub-basement area pulled around him it
had no idea that another creature was
already sneaking up behind it getting
ready to strike before 096 could even
react several whip-like orange tentacles
wrapped around its Limbs and began
delivering an antagonizing shock through
its body more tentacles came in soon
after wrapping around the Shy Guy's body
and face delivering shock After Shock
After Shock with its millions of tiny
venomous Stinger barbs for a second
second it seemed like the surprise
attack might actually be able to subdue
the monster but little did the shy guys
attacker the Monstrous real Stinger
Flynn know that attacking it was just
another way to activate its Infamous
rage State the second that Stinger Flynn
relented even just for a moment the shy
guy grabbed him by the tentacles and
slammed him into the watery floor again
and again and again until the grip of
his tentacles loosened around the Shy
Guy's body and he was defenseless with
stinger panicked and immobilized the shy
guy released the full force of his
Supernatural Fury striking the Demonic
jellyfish with his fists until what was
left couldn't be distinguished from the
water it used to be floating in Stinger
Flynn had been completely annihilated
the shy guy once again temporarily
returned to a state of calm and wandered
out of this watery basement into a
nearby hallway where everything was
bright and dry the walls were painted in
garish childlike drawings of a jungle
with janky looking animals the shy guy
paid no mind to any of it all he wanted
was to find somewhere that he could
actually be alone and away from prying
eyes of all these freaks this dream was
shortlived because as soon as the shy
guy found a new room a wide open
Auditorium filled with inflatable jungle
trees like a crude play area he was
being stalked yet again a powerful
muscular Predator with veins stretching
over its bulging muscles and blue skin
it knew that this Intruder had already
killed two of its fellow Garden dwellers
but this time it would put the spindly
pale Stranger in its place the shyi
heard something rumbling towards it from
behind and turned upon hearing the blood
curdling war cry of ugaa boaa it was the
gorilla like Captain fiddles with
strands of saliva hanging from his tusks
he leaped onto the Shy Guy and began
pounding into its hideous face with his
huge blue fists Captain fiddles would
destroy the shy guy pound him into the
concrete until he stopped moving the one
thing that Captain fiddles didn't expect
was for the shy guy to start fighting
back and he was about to learn the hard
truth that the shy guy could fight a lot
harder than him the scp's spindly but
immensely powerful arms grabbed Captain
fiddles by the shoulders and threw him
into the wall causing huge cracks to
crawl up towards the ceiling before
Captain fiddles could even think about
wrenching himself free the shy guy
leaped to his feet and bound it over to
him the shy guy grabbed Captain fiddles
by the ankles and ripped him out of the
wall letting his body drop to the floor
and then unleashing hell upon Him
Captain fiddles would have begged for
mercy if he wasn't already dead before
the shy guy could even begin to calm
down a trapo opened in the floor beneath
him dropping him into a new area a
multicolored maze where 096 was trapped
like a helpless rat with the body count
of an atomic bomb once again the shy guy
did the need to go looking for trouble
because trouble was already on its way
the pure white cat like ban bolina
pounced from a sharp corner in the Maze
claws bared she jumped onto the shy guy
latching onto him and cl trying to
scratch his nightmare of a face if the
shy guy had ever possessed anything
resembling patience he would have run
out long before now he grabbed van
bolina shrugging off the pain of her
claws and tossing her into the darkness
high above she flew off with a C like
yell and hit some distant ceiling with a
crunch suffice to say she wouldn't be
back to bother the shy guy again tired
and angry the pale Abomination didn't
feel like wandering through a maze
instead it just charged straight through
destroying a colorful wall after
colorful wall when it encountered
whatever was behind this extremely
frustrating afternoon it would destroy
it with extreme prejudice that was
almost certainty after breaking through
one more wall the shy guy tumbled out
into to a strange room where a grinning
red creature was waiting for him wearing
two party hats on top of his head this
was no mere Lackey it was ban ban
himself the one behind this nightmarish
kindergarten he stared right into the
shy guy's face with no fear at all
almost like he knew something that the
shy guy didn't and it was true he had no
plan to fight the shy guy himself he'd
brought a champion with him as the shy
guy started to scream and rage all the
boxes behind band ban tumbled out of the
way as a huge figure Rose a behemoth at
least 50 ft tall with green skin giant
teeth and huge staring eyes it was jumbo
Josh and if the shy guy wanted to
graduate from this nightmare
kindergarten it would need to defeat him
and ban ban the shy guy growled digging
its claws into the ground and preparing
to charge forward challenge accepted
mobile task force operatives f fire
their assault rifles at the approaching
crowd of SCP 008 zombies only to be
swarmed and overwhelmed administrative
staff tried to activate the
communications arrays and contact help
from another site but SCP 106 has melted
all the wiring already keeping them cut
off from the outside world Abel is
drawing his obsidian blades to slice and
dice some unfortunate guards and SC SCP
682 is running rampant in the Halls
devouring everyone he sees
in site 19 thanks to the biggest
Containment Breach in modern record the
inmates are now running the Asylum the
guards are no longer in control the
researchers have no information and the
administrative staff is powerless this
time the anomalies are on top how will
our heroes at the SCP Foundation fair
when the roles are reversed First We
join Dr cleff the most trigger happy
researcher that the SCP Foundation ever
employed he never met an anomaly he
didn't propose to terminate most of
these anomalies he'd be happy to tell to
their faces he wanted to terminate them
this was a decision he may have wanted
to go back on now that the roles were
reversed and he found himself strapped
to a table with a number of belts he
struggled against his restraints but it
was no good he was stuck tight standing
above him was a d-class possessed by SC
cp035 the possessive mask carrying one
of Dr clef's favorite shotguns a squad
of cackling vengeful members of d-class
personnel stood behind him egging him on
the possessive mask laughed and spoke Dr
alto clef I have conferred with my
associates the esteemed members of the
SCP foundation's d-class personnel and
in light of your poor conduct
belligerent nature and repeated acts of
excessive aggression we think continued
containment would present undo risks
instead we recommend immediate
termination Dr klef gulped and the
possessive mask cocked his shotgun
elsewhere in the facility SCP
0761 AEL The Immortal Warrior was
running some training simulations the
exact kind that mobile task force
operatives might run but with a Twist
this time it was ael's training and he
was using some captive mobile Task Force
officers as training equipment he'd
taken away their guns and in instead
gave every single one of them one of his
swords which it probably goes without
saying they weren't quite as Adept with
as he was not that Abel cared when he
was ready to begin his training
simulation he pulled out a blade in each
hand and jumped down into the training
area the sword wielding MTF operatives
were shaking in their boots as he
approached the biggest most Psychopathic
smile stretched across his face the
second that one of the MTF operatives
made the terrible mistake of raising his
sword and running in Abel effortlessly
parried him and the slaughter began by
the time this training simulation was
done Abel was the only Survivor and none
of the MTF operatives would later revive
themselves in a giant black sarcophagus
meanwhile SCP 682 was working on a more
personal project one of the SCP
foundation's most enduring efforts was
attempting to terminate SCP 682 at all
costs using some methods that even
hardcore sadists would describe as
exceptionally cruel and the
Irreplaceable Dr Jack brigh had
contributed more than his fair share of
potential killing methods including
using his anomalous Medallion to
forcibly insert his Consciousness into
SCP 682s own but now that the roles were
reversed 682 wanted a little of that
sweet sweet payback after devouring his
fill of random researchers and guards
682 decided to narrow his Focus onto Dr
brght that's exactly why he had Dr brgh
hanging by his arms from a pair of
chains above the same tank of acid that
682 had been wasting away in for decades
now 682 couldn't wait for Dr brigh to
experience the pain he'd known for so
long well doctor we've tried burning
crushing and freezing and still it seems
we can't give you a permanent death
we'll try the acid now I can tell you
from personal experience.
this acid is very very effective 682
pulled the lever on the ground loosening
the chains around Dr Bright's arms as
the wise cracking researcher dropped
down towards the acid 682 felt a
profound sense of calm SCP 049 on the
other hand was feeling a profound sense
of excitement after all he'd spent
months being experimented on by
low-level research staff after having
his own rights to research taken away
after a minor incident involving the
death and subsequent reanimation of
senior researcher Hamlin and now with
the tables turned and the roles reversed
everything was about to change 049 had a
whole gaggle of captured researchers
confined in a Cell the perfect testing
stock for his next series of experiments
into the pestilence the plague doctor
opened his bag and began taking out each
one of his frightening medical tools
laying them across a nearby table and
ignoring the cries of protest from the
cell he feels no pity for them they
should be honored to become part of such
a towering body of research their
sacrifices would not be meaningless as
their deaths would contribute to saving
so many other lives the exact same logic
that the SCP Foundation uses to justify
every piece of collateral damage that
they've ever incurred but as the plague
doctor walks towards the cell with a
scalpel wondering which of the terrified
researchers he'd select first none of
them really appreciated the irony
someone that did very much appreciate
irony was SCP 106 one of the most cruel
calculating and sadistic anomalies that
the foundation has ever had to contain
while he wasn't nearly as talkative as
some of the other Sapient humanoid
anomalies out there he was still
extremely intelligent and he'd been
observing methods that the SCP
Foundation had been using to contain him
for all these years the one he found the
most frustrating was their tendency to
make the area around his containment
cell extremely complicated knowing it
would confuse him and make it that much
harder for him to escape
scp-106 had been planning his particular
method of roll reversal for years and
little by little building it in his
beloved pocket Dimension as soon as the
anomalies took control of site 19 SCP
106 captured a gaggle of researchers and
guards and dragged them to his hellish
pocket Dimension there he trapped each
one of them inside cells in a Twisted
version of site 19 as each one tried to
escape they found that they were trapped
in the same complex network of obstacles
they'd always used to keep SCP 106
contained the one difference is in this
case they were being chased by SCP
106 and they weren't just playing for
their freedom they were playing for
their lives it was the most fun as cp16
had had in years but not all of the
anomalies subject to the mass site 19
reversal were acting out violent Revenge
fantasies the anomalous Butler Mr Deeds
summoned up by the SCP 662 Bell was
enjoying a real change of Peace under
anomalous control during the early hours
of the Containment Breach a researcher
had rung the bell and summon Mr Deeds to
help them Control the Chaos but for some
reason Beyond anyone's understanding Mr
Deeds had simply refused the orders not
because they weren't possible as is the
case of his usual commands but because
today he simply did not feel like it and
if the foundation Personnel who summoned
him didn't want him to alert more
dangerous anomalies of their presence
they needed to wait on him for a change
it's not like they had any choice in the
matter this time that's why Mr Deeds was
reclining in the comfiest chair they
could find sipping on a p colada and
getting a foot massage from a nervous
Junior researcher even the anomaly who
devoted his entire life to service was
on this special day the deciding to take
a load off and treat himself to some
much needed rest and relaxation and who
could blame him really as SCP 1370 on
the other hand was choosing to make war
rather than love typically this tiny
pathetic automaton known as pant was
little more than an amusingly useless
sentient toy with delusions of grandeur
he wasn't an anomaly that anyone took
seriously and even fewer people feared
him in short SCP 13370 was perhaps The
Biggest Loser in all the foundation's
containment but now that the roles had
been reversed he wasn't so pathetic
anymore during the initial chaos of the
Containment Breach while all the
security Personnel was distracted by the
significantly more dangerous anomalies
the pbot somehow managed to sneak his
way into the experimental weapons lab
that's where he got his hands on a 40
wat phased plasma rifle which promptly
fused to his little robot arm allowing
him to enact a spre of chaotic shootings
across his section of the site he
tackled in his tinny robotic voice as
guards and researchers fled from him he
leveled his plasma rifle and fired
glowing hot blasts in all directions
while declaring himself to be the
immutable meca Lord of all creation and
when he had such a deadly tool in his
hands one that with a single shot could
superheat your skeleton into radioactive
Ash nobody dared to dispute such a claim
oh how the tables had turned but those
weren't the only researchers in deep
trouble the grand roll reversal had
resulted in a lot of researchers with
less than ethical scientific conduct
getting a frightening Taste of their own
medicine this is exactly what happened
when a gang of the infamous laughing men
SCP
2419 the vengeful bodies of soulless
d-class Personnel managed to get their
hands on the dog bodied senior
researcher Dr C pathos Crow Dr Crow had
always been an aggressive user of SCP
158 also known as the soul extractor
using this machine he had ripped out the
souls of many DCL classes as part of his
frowned upon Olympia project naturally
this role reversal would not result in
Dr Crow getting a favorable outcome
instead three laughing men forced him
into the soul extractor which promptly
removed his soul and placed it into a
jar a jar which The Laughing Man then
decided to play around of catch with and
honestly as adorable as he may be I
don't think there's any denying that Dr
Crow had this one coming maybe don't
extract so many people's Souls next time
doctor but for some anomalies the rooll
reversal was not a time for relaxation
rampaging or Revenge it was a time for
personal development this was the case
for SCP 2430 The Immortal Hitler clone
with all the chaos that was going on The
Daily staff Hitler punching roster had
fallen by the wayside allowing the
anomalous ex dictator to leave his cell
for once and wander around the facility
eventually he found himself in a room
he'd never been in before the site 19
employee Library which featured a wide
range of both anomalous and
non-anomalous texts this was where he
found and decided out of sheer curiosity
to read a variety of personal
development and anti-racism books that
taught him the error of his ways for the
first time and in what was perhaps the
biggest role reversal of the entire
breach he began to realize that the
philosophy of discrimination he'd held
in his previous life had hurt millions
of people and put him on the road to
nowhere but before he could go any
further down the road of
self-development the long awaited
Cavalry arrived the fact that site 19
had dropped out of contact with other
nearby sites for over 10 hours had
raised alarm Bells with the 05 Council
who dispatched a wide array of mobile
task forces to save the terrorized
populace of Psych 19 and return
Foundation control all of the days roll
reversals were re- reversed back into
their original state that's right
everything had been returned to normal
for now anyway the entire Foundation was
in turmoil researchers were getting into
heated fist fights with security
officers who in turn were retaliating in
fits of unbridled animalistic rage the
facility had erupted into such a frenzy
with chairs being hurled across testing
Chambers and armories raided for weapons
to escalate the brawl into a far
deadlier incident tables were overturned
and used as cover as the foundation's
own staff turned on each other and
before long in allout war had erupted
but this wasn't a battle of one side
versus another no this was a wild and
rampant free-for-all everyone was out to
get everyone else viewing their own
colleagues as mortal enemies and it was
all thanks to Junior the spawn of the
shy guy only a month before the
foundation had been subject to another
bout of chaos although this one was much
more subdued than the explosive battle
that would later sweep the facility
everyone was a buzz researchers ignored
their work and some security Personnel
even abandoned their posts to see what
all the fuss was about something was
very wrong with scp096 the creature was
normally docile unless directly observed
it spent the majority of its time just
pacing around in its containment chamber
or staying hunched over in a fetal
position crying to itself in fact it was
so often sobbing quietly and making all
manner of discontented noises that this
became known as its usual Behavior at
first almost nobody had noticed that
something was even a miss all seemed
right with the miserable monster that is
until the screaming started it was a
loud shrieking sound that pierced the
eardrums of whoever heard it then
proceeded to climb down their spine and
bring a chill to their bones making
their blood run icy cold and causing
their skin to be littered with
Goosebumps the screeching disturbing
noise flooded out of scp096 his cell
reverberating off of every wall and
going down every Corridor until not one
member of foundation Personnel could
ignore it it was unlike anything they'd
ever heard from the creature before this
Primal howling seemed to put everyone
who heard it on edge not just because it
was unfamiliar but because everyone
uncannily seemed to know what the
screams were indicating pain perhaps
even the worst physical pain that scp096
had ever felt what if the shy guy was
dying something had to be done but
therein lay a hurdle to clear first how
could the foundation help even offer
medical assistance if needed to a
creature they couldn't even safely look
at what options are there for even
getting somebody close enough to examine
the shy guy without it killing them they
were limited but a crowd of the SCP
foundation's best and brightest
researchers had already congregated
outside the containment chamber housing
096 after they heard its screams surely
between them they could come up with an
idea hearing the shy guy continuing to
Howl in agony one researcher came
forward and made a suggestion there was
a device another Foundation researcher
had developed code named scramble
resembling standard issue night vision
goggles one Dr Dan had created these
scramble goggles to identify 0 96's face
and digitally alter it so that the
wearer was unable to see its face
essentially it edited out the shy guy's
face in real time so that its homicidal
rage State couldn't be activated the use
of Dr Dan's scramble goggles had
previously led to a catastrophic
incident that claimed the lives of
mobile task force to 1 also known as Big
Brother The Scrambled devices allowed
the wearer's brain to receive a single
nanosecond of scp096 unscrambled before
the image was altered by the goggles so
needless to say since time was running
out to help the creature and there were
no other viable options for doing so the
scramble goggles would need some serious
refinement and fast work as quickly as
they could the gathered gaggle of
researchers requisitioned an old pair of
scrambled goggles and started trying to
improve them tinkering equipment
Specialists put their heads together
with computer science Engineers as they
coded like crazy all underscored by the
continued screams of scp096
then without warning or even a hint of
what had happened inside the cell the
screaming suddenly stopped everyone
outside the containment chamber stopped
for a second falling deathly silent the
goggles were almost ready but were they
too late to save the shy guy the
security Personnel who had also gathered
in response to the sound all Drew straws
with the officer pulling the shortest
being the one tasked with venturing into
the containment chamber he was handed
the goggles and instructed that they
would blur his version entirely for a
few seconds while the scramble software
had a chance to work then once the
device had double triple and quadruple
checked the results the goggles would
activate fully and in theory worked the
way Dan had originally intended although
the track record of the scramble project
meant that the officer was hardly
reassured as he entered the dark dingy
containment chamber he couldn't see a
thing ahead of him his vision totally
obscured as the goggles started running
the newly updated version of the
scramble software they were untested so
naturally the security officer's nerves
were at Peak levels worried the device
might fail and any second his eyes would
be greeted by the face of scp096 he
could tell the creature was still alive
there was a low sound of panting breaths
coming from the far corner of the
chamber indicating that it hadn't
perished although it might have been
injured a sudden beep from the scramble
goggles startled the officer the device
had made its checks and was ready to
activate however an unexpected message
blinked on the heads up display that
read warning multiple subjects detected
luckily enough when the goggles
activated the officer was relieved to
see they had worked scp096 his face was
a riny pixelated mess the creatures
showed little noticeable sign of any
injuries too and just seemed to be
gently rocking itself in the corner but
quickly the reason and perhaps even the
cause of scp096 is earlier scream soon
became obvious though nobody had entered
the containment cell before the security
officer it seemed the shy guy wasn't
alone standing at about a third of SCP
96's considerable height was another shy
guy or at least another version of a
creature almost identical save for being
shorter it wobbled on its elongated legs
like it wasn't quite used to standing
upright it kept both arms outstretched
towards scp096 almost as though it was
reaching out for a hug but the shy guy
stayed in the corner cing away from the
other creature through his scramble
goggles the security officer looked on
in disbelief at the scene before him
somehow completely unpredictably scp096
had spawned an offspring it had had a
baby there was a general a of disbelief
among the assembled staff outside the
containment chamber after the security
officer had relayed what had happened
most were quick to write it off as an
impossibility they'd studied scp096 for
a long time and it had been the only
anomaly known to the foundation matching
its own very particular description
there had been no other cited in the
wild it didn't seem to be part of a
species as far as anyone knew but other
researchers refuted this clim clim given
scp096 his ability to travel at
anomalous speeds and kill those that
looked at it it stood to reason there
could be others maybe the foundation
wasn't aware of a whole species of shy
guys because anyone who'd ever seen one
didn't live long enough to report it
then someone mentioned that it wasn't
entirely unprecedented for anomalies to
have Offspring either a long while
before as cp49 the infamous beak Mass
plague doctor had laid an egg which had
hatched into SCP
049-j a smaller version of himself
composed of moss and wads of tissue
trying to apply logical understanding to
each and every anomaly was a paradoxical
exercise in futility all anomalies had
their own rules even rules the
foundation had never observed before
after a great deal of deliberation and
additional improvements of the scramble
technology a research team was sent into
the containment chamber to retrieve
scp096 is progyny the the parent
creature was still shying away from its
creation perhaps because it didn't want
to raise it in the way that meant the
child inherited its deadly sense of
self-consciousness then again maybe the
shy guy was just afraid of what it had
Unleashed on an unsuspecting Foundation
initial testing with The Offspring
creature revealed it was perfectly
healthy and seemingly very much unlike
its predecessor until any official SCP
Foundation designation number could be
assigned the team examining it took to
calling it scp096
junor or shortened to Simply junior
junior regarded the foundation
scientists with curiosity intrigued by
them as well as their surroundings
picking up medical instruments before
very carefully placing them back where
it found them treating every item it
touched like they had been made of the
finest most delicate glass one of the
researchers likened its movements to
that of a lemur or other similar
primates but with the reserved timid and
docile nature of a well domesticated pet
that was at first naturally the SCP
Foundation being the organization that
it is there quickly became an interest
in whether Junior displayed the same
anomalous traits as scp096 call it
curiosity or caution they wanted to know
if it would react the same way when
observed without the protection of
scramble goggles so a test was devised
seating a member of d-class Personnel in
the same room as Junior and tasked only
with looking at the shy guys spawn
everyone gathered with baited breath the
research team watching from an
observation desk all of them wearing
scramble goggles to blur Junior's face
as a blindfolded d-class was brought in
and stood opposite of Junior all of them
expected that the test would unfold in a
particular way which made it all the
more surprising when as the DCL classes
blindfold was removed nothing happened
Junior regarded the convict with the
same general curiosity as it had for
everyone else but beyond that showed no
change in Behavior no wild crying no
murderous rage State nothing are we sure
this is actually the shy guys kid one of
the researchers choked with the test
concluded and then repeated a few extra
times for good measure Junior was deemed
a safe class anomaly much like SCP 999
or Josie the half cat it was decided
that Junior be allowed to wander freely
around the facility while initially a
little unnerving to some staff when they
first saw him without goggles people
quickly warned to Junior he was like a
small monkey from a safari park although
with the added benefit of not stealing
anyone's iPhone or wallet but at least
until shortly after around nearly a
month had passed since Junior's birth
and since then an odd change had been
noted in scp096 the shy guys seemed
calmer more at ease and far less anxious
what's more researchers discovered that
for the first time ever he could be
observed however before they could
investigate further all hell broke loose
it started in the holding cells where
DCL classes were housed initially
written off as fights between inmates
that got a little too out of hand but
soon the foundation's own Personnel
started to violently attack each other
it was sparked at random a state of
animalistic rage that was focused on
their fellow staff members the people
they worked with the people who saw them
every day and it didn't stop those
working at the facility were seemingly
possessed by an inescapable urge to harm
those around them as if punishing each
other for just looking at them by the
time a mobile task force was ordered to
step in and diffuse the situation the
scene they arrived to was one of utter
chaos further examination uncovered that
those who had seen Junior's face had
been exposed to an anomalous effect
looking at the creature gave the
Observer the same rageful reaction to
being observed as scp096 they were
compelled to kill anyone who saw them
however most insidiously this didn't
seem to take effect instantly in fact
those affected only entered their
Collective rage state after everyone in
the facility had interacted with Junior
at least once almost like it had been
waiting to infect everyone while the
remainder of the foundation mopped up
the aftermath of the incident some
theorized that scp096 had somehow
expelled all its
self-consciousness all of its negative
traits into its progeny this was
supposedly why the shy guy seemed so
much calmer so much so that it could
even be observed whether Junior simply
couldn't contain all SCP 96's negativity
or intentionally spread it to everyone
else around it it is unknown the only
solution to get things back to normal
was to put the shy guys
self-consciousness back to where it came
from Hello one and all and welcome back
to the
anamatronic for projecting any seemingly
improbable scenario for your viewing
Indulgence and today we decided Ed to do
something slightly different with it
here at SCP explained we usually
activate the
anamatronic characters like Doctor
Strange fighting the Scarlet king or AEL
crossing paths with Batman but this
scp-914 in it the shy guy was tricked
into entering the input Booth of the
anomalous refinement machine during a
Containment Breach what emerged was
maybe the handsomest man to ever live
Beautiful both on the outside and within
a lot of our comments pointed out that
this refined version of 096 felt akin to
a gigachad and that got us thinking what
if SC scp096 was to encounter the real
gigachad well the
and has a few different answers for us
scenario one or as we like to call it
the obvious outcome pits the thin
humanoid anomaly Against The Man Behind
the meme Ernest kov is a Russian fitness
trainer and model forever immortalized
in the animals of Internet history by a
series of black and white photoshopped
pictures that garnered him the nickname
of gigachad thanks to his Practically
Perfect 90° jawline and muscular
physique kov seemingly unknowingly
became the architect type for the Ultram
masculine handsome man however The Man
Behind the gigachad meme is still just a
man the infamous photos of him were
heavily edited for an art project known
as Sleek in tears and while Ernest does
Sport some impressive muscles from all
his time at the gym that strength isn't
enough to save him from the shy guy
after all he is still just a man
according to the
anamatronics the most likely outcome if
the two were ever to meet would end
pretty similarly to to the Grim fate of
many others who have gazed upon the face
of scp096 the moment Ernest looks at the
creature he would in all likelihood
activate 0 96's rage State his physique
and above average level of Fitness might
give him a slight Advantage allowing him
to perhaps outrun the shy guy for longer
than most but ultimately Ernest kov
would be able to run but not hide from
scp096 the creature would track him down
and hone in on him with anomalous speed
dispatching him before returning to its
usual docile sobbing State the result
and scp096
victory now we know what you're thinking
is that really it we had the same
reaction too but hold on for a minute
after giving the machine an additional
set of variables we were able to get a
few more interesting outcomes out of the
anamatronic 2 shy harder of course
Ernest kov might be the face of an
intern Meme and ultimately just a very
strong Russian man in comparison to the
anomalous traits of scp096 but the
gigachad the gigachad is more than a man
so much more than the sum of his Parts
existing within the online zag guy since
as early as 2017 the gigachad is far
more powerful than a mere mortal he
doesn't just represent idealized
standards of overe exaggerated
masculinity like the Action Movie heroes
of the 1980s the gigachad embodies those
ideas he is the very notion of a
physically perfected human specimen
given form you may not like it but Peak
Performance doesn't even come close to
the gigachad and neither does scp096
even at the top of its game the creature
quite literally pales in comparison to
its imposing opponent in scenario 2 shy
harder the
anamatronic that if the two were to meet
the scales would tip in the complete
opposite direction from the first
outcome for that was scp096 against the
man but against the meme himself well
this fight is no contest as a matter of
fact it's hardly even a fight certainly
not a fair one and instead is more of an
execution from the moment the
Unstoppable Tower of muscle and perfect
angular jawline that is the gigachad
clasps eyes on scp096 it's practically
the beginning of the end the shy guy
doesn't even lift bro but gigachad can
bench 1 million times his own body
weight in his sleep so when scp096 comes
racing towards him intent on killing him
just for looking at its screeching wide
jawed face the gigachad does what the
gigachad does best he lifts grabbing a
scp096 with ease as it comes to him
screeching gigachad casually hoists the
creature off the ground although he's
only using the tiniest portion of his
immense and Infinite Strength it's more
than enough Force to send the shy guy
soaring upwards crashing through
multiple ceilings as it sent hurdling up
the numerous floors of the foundation
facility above of course being lifted is
hardly going to kill the shy guy
outright the creature is known to be
invulnerable after all but it's not like
gigachad can go down easily either don't
forget this is no mere mortal but an
internet meme incarnate and on the
internet nothing ever dies his Perpetual
exist as part of online history aside
the gigachad is so strong that no doubt
his abs could withstand the Firepower of
any conventional weapon realizing that
even if it could reach him it couldn't
even scratch the gigachad scp096 would
undoubtedly begin a downward spiral the
shy guy is a creature so insecure in
itself and its appearance that it kills
anyone who so much has glances at its
face in photos so being presented with
the living embodiment of an idea it
could would never even hope to attain
the biceps the perfect right angle
jawline it's all too much sending us
scp096 into a complete meltdown the
creature would be neutralized once and
for all by the very existence of the
gigachad resulting in his victory okay
so we're one point to scp096 and one to
gigachad and most people would maybe
consider leaving it there but not us we
wanted more than that you see we quickly
realize that the Ron's second scenario
was based on a lot of earlier iterations
of the gigachad meme don't get us wrong
that version of the ultimate man could
still easily destroy the shy guy but
around March of 2021 the infamous
photoshopped images of erns kov started
to be used in slightly different formats
that's the thing about memes they're not
only Immortal forever logged in the
ancient texts of the Wayback machine and
compilation videos here on YouTube but
memes are also adaptable they can evolve
and change finding new variations as
time goes on as such the average fan
versus average enjoyer meme saw a new
use of the gigachad before the gigachad
this notion of the ideal Ultram
masculine specimen was based on let's be
honest some pretty outdated ideas about
what it means to be a man after all it
takes more than muscle to be a man not
every man or masculine presenting person
has to work out until they're built like
like a brick wall perhaps the real
Measure of a Man is how sincere
sensitive and supportive you can be as
well as standing by your interests
rather than caving to Old societal
standards of masculinity and after we
updated our data the
anamatronic outcome or what we like to
call scenario 3 the average scp096
enjoyer in this projection the Giga
Chad's true strength isn't just his
masculine in physique and his
unattainable standards instead it's in
part the inherent adaptability of his
status as a meme but also his compassion
just like before he's more than able to
resist SCP 96's attacks and the
creatures insecurity comes out put on
full display when presented with Giga
Chad's sharp jawline but rather than
overcome his anomalous adversary by
fighting him this scenario sees the
gigachad comforting the shy guy through
calm empathy and words of affirmation he
reminds scp096 that true acceptance of
oneself comes from within and that
message strikes a chord with the
creature in a turn of events none of us
saw coming the gigachad offers to help
scp096 overcome his crippling and deadly
sense of insecurity the pair start using
the on-site gym together after hours
when there aren't any innocent
Foundation Personnel around there Giga
Chad not only offers to introduce scps
96 to an exercise regimen if that's what
the creature wants but also helps the
shy guy work on his confidence they form
a friendship with scp096 taking a liking
to working out not because it wants to
be buff like its new friend the gigachad
but more so because doing so makes it
feel more comfortable in its own skin
scp096 gradually starts to like itself
more even eating healthier thanks to
Giga Chad's advice eventually the shy
guy begins looking far more content and
even starts to develop self-confidence
it's not often that a story involving
scp096 exists with the creature getting
to achieve some semblance of Happiness
well there is one that comes to mind the
very same Shy Guy story that sent us on
this particular streak of pitting it
against the gigachad in the first place
but what if we put them together would
coming across a refined scp096 spell the
N for the gigachad or would the muscular
masculine meme undo the Shy Guy's
previous happy ending well according to
the
quite the understanding of him but
perhaps the photograph from the Desir
camera was more of a metaphor than what
scp096 or David really desired wasn't
specifically the researcher who' studied
him but a partner who understood him
someone to call and equal enter the
gigachad according to the calculations
made by the
anamatronic there the moment he and
David saw each other was like the
meeting of an Unstoppable force and an
immovable object neither one rushed to
solve the encounter with violence both
the gigachad and scp096 appreciated each
other's aesthetic appeal both were
remarkably handsome and one couldn't
bear the thought of ridding the world of
the other instead it was love at first
sight both David formerly known as
scp096 and the gigachad fell head over
heels in love with each other and
looking at both it was not hard to see
why they were a pair of fine perfectly
chiseled fellas and they instantly hit
it off the newly established couple
enjoyed each other's company spending
time in deep conversations scp096
introducing his new partner to his
friends at the foundation while gigachad
was comfortable with his own masculinity
to express his feelings towards David
without fear or judgment no relationship
is perfect of course for a short time a
sliver of David's old self reemerged the
shy guy in him worried that perhaps his
relationship with the gigachad was based
purely on both of their extreme good
looks and was nothing more than
superficial but by being an embodiment
of healthy idealized masculinity the
gigachad was able to sense something was
wrong with David and rather do the
insecure thing of letting it Fester he
addressed it directly and they discussed
the issue in a healthy mature and
constructive way not just so they could
put SCP Z 96's worried to rest but so
that both of them could further
strengthen their relationship and grow
as people and of course gigachad wasn't
just attracted to scp096 is refined good
looks far from being superficial he
recognized that David was a complete
person beautiful both inside and out and
loved him as a whole not just because
they were both conventionally attractive
on the surface scp096 and the gigachad
stayed together for the rest of to their
lives or as we decided to name this
fourth scenario from the
anamatronic speech family can mean many
things to many people and when it comes
to the bizarre world of scps family can
be found in some very unexpected places
take the two brothers Cain and Abel SCP
073 and SCP 076-2
respectively as an example their shared
history goes back centuries and from
what little we've been able to learn
directly from the source the two seem to
have the mother of all sibling rivalries
Abel can become visibly enraged at the
very mention of Cain's name whereas C
has a more subdued response calmly but
firmly urging inquisitive research not
to discuss the matter any further
whatever bad blood came between them is
not fully known but it likely has
something to do with the nature of their
anomalous abilities Cain has the power
to drain the lives of plant life with
merely a touch while able has the power
of Resurrection returning from the grave
every time he was dealt a lethal blow
the two were natural opposites and yet
they were also undeniably family and
their case is not wholly unique within
the SCP Foundation as there is also
another pair of completely antithetical
beings in containment who surprisingly
share a family tree and much like the
dynamic between SCP 073 and SCP 076-2
there was one side of the pair that
could express nothing but distress at
the mere mention of the other and it was
by far not the one that most would
expect enter SCP 682 one of the most
deadly ker class scps that the
foundation had ever known a reptilian
monstrosity responsible for multiple
containment breaches capable
withstanding the total punishment of
weapons both conventional and anomalous
and hell bent on following through on
the personal violent destruction of
every living being in existence it is an
anomalous creature so overwhelmingly
powerful and indestructible that one
could easily assume that it was
incapable of fear and in most cases that
would be an astute observation but not
when it comes to the matter of SCP 999
the Tickle Monster in stark contrast to
scp-682's viciousness SCP 999 is a
bundle of pure unadulterated Bliss
resembling a smiley face glob of
sunshine and honey SCP 99's main
anomalous property is its ability to
bring lasting joy to all beings that
interact with it prolong contact with
the little guy has even been proven to
cure depression and ease trauma what's
more as SCP 999 seems to actively seek
out others to share these benefits with
and often does so through play or other
forms of socialization SCP 999 is
benevolent in just about every way that
a being could be and that makes it very
different from most of the Sapient
anomalies in containment it is
especially different from SCP 682 even
though they have a common origin while
the family resemblance is far from
striking these two scps are half
siblings not as closely related as Cain
and Abel but that is still a lot closer
than most researchers would expect both
of them were allegedly born from Human
mothers who had undergone a horrific
ritual at the hands of an obscure cult
known as the children of the Scarlet
King as the ominous name of the cult
implies the members of the children of
the Scarlet King worshiped a nightmarish
deity known as The Scarlet King this
interdimensional super beinging has
become known to the CP Foundation is one
of the most threatening anomalous forces
in existence and some have even
suggested that the Scarlet King is the
ultimate threat that the foundation must
overcome if they wish to achieve their
goals to put it a different way the
Scarlet King is like the last boss of a
traditional RPG video game a primal
source of all evil and suffering in the
world which must be defeated at any cost
his powers are so great that our world
is merely one of many that he names to
conquer and reduce to rubble and ruin
and all of us mortals can take a bit of
solace in the fact that the Scarlet King
split interests mean that he is unlikely
to invade our world directly anytime
soon he is not without his schemes and
contingencies though of which the vile
machinations of the children of the
Scarlet King were surely one the two
ordinary human woman who would go on to
give birth to both SCP 682 and SCP 999
were part of a group of seven
individuals total all of whom had been
imprisoned by the children of the
Scarlet King and were found in the late
stages of pregnancy at the Colts
compound upon being discovered by the
SCP Foundation these women were placed
in containment and designated as SCP 231
over the duration of their containment
the instances of SCP 231 have given
birth to various anomalies most of these
anomalies have been catastrophically
dangerous CER class anomalies and have
each been the cause of hundreds of
casual
those which could be destroyed through
violence were neutralized before ever
receiving a designation with the obvious
exception being SC CP 682 despite the
foundation's best efforts even more
exceptional is SCP 999 which while just
as anomalous and nigh indestructible as
the others did not share its siblings
capacity for cruelty and Slaughter of
all the humans that were unlucky enough
to become part of SCP 231 only the
mother of SCP 99 99 was able to survive
and make a full recovery from the trauma
that she suffered at the hands of the
cult this unexpectedly happy outcome was
apparently thanks to SCP 99's ability to
heal those around it including its human
mother SCP 682 the hard to destroy
reptile and SCP 999 the Tickle Monster
are the two most notable members of the
SCP 231 brood and while the Scarlet King
had more than likely hoped that his
actual biological children would join
forces to drown our world in misery and
pain this will most likely never come to
pass that is because as CP 682 and SCP
999 are like oil and water and the one
that has been successful in Rising above
the other has unmistakably been as CP
999 this surprising truth became known
to the foundation after a rather
eventful cross test between the two most
contrary spawn of the Scarlet king and
the findings from that experiment point
towards a possible long-term solution in
dealing with the interdimensional Elder
evil as well as his children adopted or
otherwise the cross test was the product
of resilient optimism from the research
team who Against All Odds were willing
to bet that SCP 999 could survive an
encounter with one of the most infamous
ker class scps the foundation had on
record nobody could be 100% sure that
999 would come out of the test unscathed
and there was not an insubstantial
amount of fear as everyone's favorite
glob of goodness was wheeled into a
shared containment for the experiment to
be carried out however the mere presence
of SCP 999 did soothe a great deal of
the worried Souls which only instilled
more confidence in the head researchers
that this would lead to a success once
SCP 999 was alone in the cell with SCP
682 the main event could begin SCP 682
had been subjected to a wide variety of
cross tests during its time in
containment and having never met or been
aware of SCP 999 prior to the test was
cautiously staring the creature down
preparing for the absolute worst with a
beaming smile on its face SCP 999 slid
forward towards the reptile causing the
ker class SCP to instinctively step
backward in response there was something
deeply unsettling about this gooey
little glob to SCP 682 but I couldn't
fathom what from appearance the
overseers of the Cross test were stunned
the sight of 682 retreating from an
entity was rare to say the least and the
adorable unimposing shape of SCP 999
made the scene playing out inside the
containment area especially surreal but
no matter how unlikely it seemed SCP 999
had begun The Sibling play date with an
insurmountable psychological advantage
as the Tickle Monster moved ever closer
SCP 682 found itself backed into a
corner with no further options the
reptile brought one of its massive
clawed down on top of the smiling blob
the entire mass of SCP 999 was
splattered into jelly upon impact for a
moment it seemed as though that was it
the researchers held their breath in
shock hoping that SCP 999 would pull
through and then their wish came true
the amorphous form of SCP 999 began to
reshape itself into the recognizable
form that we all know and love it
proceeded to crawl up scp-682's body
towards the nape of its neack once there
the tickle monster began doing what it
does best cuddles and lots of them 682
was certainly caught off guard by this
unusual occurrence and more than that it
was falling fast under SCP 999 spell of
benevolence the lizard began to stomp
its claws overcome with sudden bounce of
uous laughter it began to vocalize in a
way that seemed uncharacteristically
enthusiastic for the ker class anomaly
happy happy I feel so happy repeated 682
as it rolled around and thrashed in the
cross testing containment chamber the
merciless tickling from SCP 999 looked
like it would be torturous for the big
reptile to endure if it wasn't so much
fun on the sidelines the foundation
Personnel cheered on their wonderful
little friend 999 as it continued to
tickle SC SCP 682 without stopping some
of the staff present were even sporting
custom t-shirts that read s SCP 999
literally cured my depression the Tickle
Monster did have a large fan base within
its containment facility after all and
returning some of the Good Vibes that
the anomaly had provided seemed like the
right thing to do at a time like this
scp-682's fits of laughter continued for
a long while and the more it went on the
more it seemed that SCP 682 was becoming
tired 999 seemed to sense its siblings
energy level decreasing ceased the
Relentless tickling and instead began to
nuzzle 682 and purr into the lizard's
ears slowly the quiet and pleasant sound
pounds of SCP 9999 L 682 into a peaceful
Slumber the hard to destroy reptile
curled up on the floor of the
containment cell almost like a sleeping
cat and began to gently snore away once
its older and more cantankerous sibling
had fallen completely asleep SCP 999
slithered off SCP 682s back and settled
down nearby to rest its own eyes the
research team couldn't help but smile
and observe for several minutes before
eventually removing 999 from the cross
test containment cell predictably this
caused SCP 682 to revert back to its
usual violent behavior and a Containment
Breach ensued shortly after however the
casualties were kept to a minimum as SCP
999 bravely helped escort several dozen
Foundation Personnel to safety by itself
what would we do without 999 we know
what SCP 682 would do without SCP 999 of
course the hard to destroy reptile would
be far less threatened while CP 999 had
expressed continued interest in another
play date with 682 the exact opposite
sentiment has been reported from its
reptilian sibling and it is simply not a
lack of affection there is an underlying
fear that motivates SCP 682s desire to
never interact with SCP 999 again while
some researchers speculated that SCP 682
felt an incredible sense of Shame when
it was observed being tickled this is
more of an armchair assumption that
projects typical human psychology onto
an anomalous being we cannot forget that
SCP 682 was born of the Scarlet King and
while SCP 999 possesses the inverse of
its father's traits SCP 682 might have
directly inherited the template for its
emotional intelligence from that very
same being While most well adjusted
humans try to avoid supposedly negative
stimuli such as embarrassment anger
sadness and fear and seek out positive
stimuli I.E happiness pleasure security
and Trust alien beings with Twisted
Minds like the Scarlet King might have
these priorities reversed to SCP 682 all
other living things are disgusting and
it wishes to destroy them but when this
tendency is examined within the context
of both SCP 999 and what we know about
the Scarlet King it becomes clear that
SCP 682 isn't an excessively prideful
being moreover SCP 682 doesn't believe
that it is doing the world or itself a
service by eliminating the aformentioned
disgusting beings we have theorized that
SC SCP 682 and SCP 999 are equal and
opposite but if that proves to be true
on the level of internal psyche SCP 682
might compulsively attack other beings
for the same reason that SCP 999
Comforts them it is a continuous
expression of empathy or more accurately
whatever one might call the The
Impossible inverse of empathy SCP 682
and the Scarlet King are not merely
indifferent to the suffering of others
both of them need to be in the presence
of those suffering beings in order to
feel any sense of meaning in their
existence after all love is the
strongest emotion but hate is the second
strongest imagine now if you can why 682
fears 999 a being that represents every
unwanted sensation and emotion that it
lives its Immortal Life hoping to avoid
in the eyes of SCP 682 SCP 999 is
precisely as horrifying as the reptile
is to ourselves welcome back SCP exlain
viewers we hope you're all having a
terrible day I'm sorry my mistake I
meant we hope you're all having a
wonderful day that unfortunate
linguistic mixup was brought on by a
force we're still struggling to
understand you see we hear at SCP
explain have fallen under the influence
of a temporal anomaly commonly referred
to as opposite day you might be under
the impression that opposite day is just
something elementary school children
came up with to excuse walking backwards
and saying things they don't mean but
you would be sorely mistaken it is all
too real and no one is immune to its
confusing effects in the spirit of
opposite day which comes for us all no
matter how much we try to prepare we
decided to fire up the good old
this annable Force might impact one of
the anomalies at the SCP Foundation we
all know what happens in the ordinary
non- opposite world when someone looks
at SCP 96's face it's one of the first
rules they tell new employees at the SCP
Foundation don't look at the shy guy's
face but what if the effect was reversed
what if seeing scp096 his face didn't
send the creature into an irrepressible
murderous rage but rather inspired the
same mindless violence Ence in the
ordinary person that saw it let's start
the simulation and find out imagine if
you can a world in which the SCP
Foundation did not have scp096 in
containment or even know of its
existence it is difficult to Envision a
creature nearly synonymous with the
foundation itself living a life outside
of those reinforced concrete and steel
walls but that is the world in which Our
Story begins deep in the snow covered
forests of remote mountain range a long
limed pale humanoid creature Ram through
the trees with Innocent abandon its
white skin and long thin arms and legs
allowed it to blend in with the snow and
the narrow trunks of the trees providing
a natural camouflage from any
Interlopers that might present a threat
the creature lived a largely peaceful
existence feeding on Roots berries and
yes some of the local Wildlife but
that's just the way things work in
nature there there are predators and
prey none good or evil in the way human
beings conceive of things all just doing
their best to stay alive the creature
that does not think of itself as scp096
had known little more than the life it
lived in the forest keeping itself
hidden from view whenever hikers or
explorers happened upon its domain it
couldn't be sure what would happen if it
was found but its instincts drove the
creature to avoid detection at all costs
but there is no way to guarantee perfect
safety in this world and as it so often
does one day something went wrong
exhausted from searching for food all
day and night the creature decided to
get some rest leaning its head against a
sturdy tree trunk and closing its eyes
for a little while it did not fall
asleep the creature wasn't capable of
sleep the way humans might think of it
but it did allow its mind to wander and
its alertness to slip it let down its
guard only for a moment but that was one
moment too many that was just enough
time for its Keen ears to miss the sound
of approaching footsteps muffled
slightly by the thick blanket of snow
covering the ground by the time it heard
one of the hikers speak it was too late
what is that I'm not sure should we get
a closer look the creature opened its
eyes to find two strangers a man and a
woman clad in heavy winter coats and
hiking gear standing just a few feet
away it turned reflexively toward the
sound and then the stranger's eyes fell
upon its face all of a sudden their
expression changed from apprehension and
curiosity to a twisted scowl a mix of
fear pain and animalistic rage the
hikers each let out a primal scream and
descended on the creature attacking it
with whatever they had on hand the woman
clawed at its face with her fingernails
and the man pulled the heavy backpack
from his shoulders and began to hit the
creature with it again and again the
creature was is far bigger and far
stronger than these two strangers and it
fought back in an attempt to defend
itself it swung its massive arms at the
hikers sending them flying in opposite
directions the woman collided with a
tree her head hitting wood with a loud
crack the man flew out of sight
disappearing over the edge of a cliff
the creature hadn't intended to hurt
them only to keep itself safe as the shy
guy began to feel a Pang of guilt for
the first time in its life it hurt heard
that horrible scream again the woman had
regained Consciousness and was resuming
her attack in full force blood dripping
from her nose and ears and staining the
White Snow Red if the shy guy was able
to speak it would have said why are you
doing this please stop I don't want to
hurt you but it couldn't say a word so
instead it decided to try and outrun the
woman instead it turned and began to
tear through the forest at a swift
unnatural gate as the woman's screams
faded away into the distance as the shy
guy had suspected she could not keep up
with its inhuman speed especially not
with the injury she had sustained during
the fight but what had happened why had
she and the man with her flown into such
a violent rage something about the side
of the creature's face had set them off
it had avoided detection for so long but
it had gotten sloppy and now its home
was no longer safe there was no time to
rest the creature would have to find
another safe place to hide and soon the
last thing it wanted was another
confrontation with a stranger who would
look at its face and then erupt into
violence as the creature continued to
run leaving the thick cover of the tree
line and making its way down the
mountain it wondered would anyone who
saw its face react the same way perhaps
this was just a uniquely awful case
perhaps this wouldn't happen again still
it would be best to stay out of sight
better safe than sorry of course the
creature not yet known as scp096 had
never heard that expression living a
completely solitary life void of any
idioms or classic sayings but its
feelings Visa safety and regret were
pretty much the same the creature
descended the treacherous Mountain
effortlessly navigating the unforgiving
rocky surface and deadly slicks of ice
by the time the creature had left its
Old Mountain Home behind the sun had set
and night had fallen on the wintry
landscape it slowed it stride then
listening for the sounds of approaching
potential threats but there appeared to
be no one around it was just the lone
pale creature the moon peeking out from
behind the clouds and the open unknown
World ahead after some time walking
completely alone the creature spotted
lights up ahead it did not understand
the concept of a town but indeed that's
what it was the creature swerved away
from the majority of the lights and
stumbled upon an old wooden Barn
apparently a abandoned and left to rot
in the elements this would be as good of
place as any to rest for a little while
to Shelter From the incoming snowstorm
and stay out of sight so the shy guy
made itself a makeshift bed of straw and
curled up there to wait out the night as
it lay there thinking about the day
before it felt a sudden wave of grief
for its lost home for the changes that
had come into its life unbidden and
turned it all upside down the creature
covered its face with its massive hands
and began to weep Weep the creature was
startled from its tears when morning
came and with it the sound of someone
breaking down the rotting wood beams
that lined the barn walls it stood
looking toward the sound and saw the
woman from the mountain pale and
shivering eyes rimmed with dark circles
and face caked in dried blood she still
screamed that horrible scream tearing
away at the wood even as it ripped up
the Flesh of her hands she was missing
one Boot and her coat was torn open
scattering tiny feathers s with every
movement she did not appear to feel the
cold the pain the exhaustion of chasing
the creature for so long she only wanted
one thing to destroy the creature by any
means necessary with a screech like a
banshee she left onto the creature's
back clawing at its face and eyes it
thrashed wildly throwing the woman to
the ground and running without a glance
back maybe she survived her fall onto
the cold hard ground or maybe it would
be the blow that actually f finished her
off the creature's only priority was to
keep moving before something else tried
to attack what the creature didn't know
was that the citizens of the nearby town
the one that it was about to run right
into the center of in its Panic were
gathering to celebrate their annual
Christmas festival complete with an
early morning parade through the town
square the same town square that the shy
guy was bounding into at that exact
moment as the shy guy raced over the
cobblestone street it ran directly into
the line of sight of a full marching
band a fleet of dancers dressed in
costumes inspired by The 12 Days of
Christmas a row of young women competing
in the Miss holiday spirit pageant and a
jolly old man dressed up as Santa Claus
in his sleigh the marching band saw the
creature first teram morphing quickly
into that same wordless rage as their
eyes fell on its face it moved to cover
itself to hide its face from view but it
was too late the marching band swarmed
around it swinging trombones and
clarinets one percussion player broke a
massive drum over the creature's head in
the struggle still it was able to
withand the musical Onslaught flinging
musicians this way and that snapping
brass instruments like twigs and
crushing Woodwinds into mulch
unfortunately as the marching band was
being dealt with the commotion had drawn
the attention of the dancers and the
pageant competitors one swarm was
replaced with two more as the performers
flew into a frenzy tackling the creature
to the ground and using every item at
their disposal to try and harm it the
creature bellowed with fear and
frustration prying itself free and
continuing to run this time it actually
remembered to cover its face just in
time to pass St Nicholas himself have
you all gone mad the old man had not
gotten the chance to see the creature's
face for himself and was horrified at
the behavior of his friends and
neighbors what has gotten into you the
creature was preoccupied with running
and keeping his face covered so it did
not see what happened next It could only
hear the sound of the Santa Claus
impersonator confronting the mob his
scandalized shouts becoming suddenly
muffled and the troubling Sound of
Silence followed by the Thundering
Stampede of crazed villagers the man had
tried to help but there was only one of
him and there were so many others intent
on destroying the creature now so the
shy guy continued to run for his life
listening to the Mob just behind it
never stopping to rest to eat or to
sleep whatever had filled these people
with such murderous impulse it made them
something a little removed from human
too they were sustained by the desire to
kill even when their bodies should have
given out long ago as the creature ran
it encountered more people that caught a
glimpse of its face that lost themselves
in the urge to destroy and became one
with a growing horde the creature could
no longer tell how long it had been
running or if it would ever be able to
stop St it was strong and seemingly
invulnerable but how long would it be
until enough people were caught in this
curse until the mob was big enough to
swallow the creature whole just when it
was beginning to contemplate giving up
lying down and letting the Sea of angry
faces overtake it a burlap bag was
thrown over its head it skitted to a
stop disoriented feeling around quick
get it out of here we need amnestics and
lots of them these people look nuts a
voice sparked orders as the creature
felt hands pushing it into a small
enclosed space the back of an SCP
Foundation van though of course the shy
guy didn't know that it could hear more
voices whispering to each other close by
I never seen anything like this what is
this thing anyway stop whatever you do
don't look at its face the scaled class
starship in nois was still suspended
against a backdrop of stars and the
colorful glow of distant nebulas Frozen
in the inky void of deep space calm
at least from the outside but inside the
main hall of the ship was far from the
silent Stillness of the Stars
pandemonium hit as the sounds of a
claxon reverberated through metal
corridors each whale punctuated by the
flash of blood red warning lights blue
looked up at the blinking strobing color
and instantly knew what it meant
emergency meeting he muttered to himself
behind the visor of his SPAC suit blue
turned heel and ran his boots clanging
against the metal floor of the corridor
he ran as fast as he could in his spacit
arriving panting to the cafeteria his
breathless wheezes fogged up his visor
but beyond he could still see the other
six fellow members of the ship's crew or
at least he thought all six of them were
there it was only as he walked closer
that he spotted someone was missing
white red green orange yellow and now
blue were all present but where was pink
you took your time blue white declared I
was over at the lower engine he panted
back it's further away sorry I'm late
ran as fast as I could what's the
situation here orange asked well I I
think we should wait for pink to get
here before we get into red started to
say only to be interrupted that's why I
called the meeting green announced pink
has gone missing but that's impossible
red immediately responded drawing a
glare from White I saw pink only a few
moments ago we we were both over in
electrical to Blue along with some of
the others that seemed a little bit but
odd if red and pink had been close to
each other then how had green known to
call the emergency meeting the room
erupted into a brief debate with white
implying in a rather spiteful way that
red knew more than he was letting on
interjecting Blue suggested that they
all split up in search for pink which
was quickly shot down white reminded the
rest of the crew mates that their ship
was in need of constant maintenance if
they didn't perform the necessary tasks
to keep it running then the anois would
never reach reach its destination report
back here when you're finished white
barked as they all split off blue
couldn't help but wonder what had gotten
white more agitated than normal however
little did any of the crew aboard the
anovas realize that they had picked up a
stowaway the creature had been slipping
through the ventilation system curiously
watching the assembled group in the
cafeteria before they broke away and
headed off into the various different
areas of the ship spotting one of the
crew mates a man wearing a bright orange
spacit the thing in the vents felt oddly
drawn to him and slithered off down the
vents in the direction orange had been
heading now while you might be forgiven
for at first expecting this extra
passenger to be some kind of Alien
Parasite that uses human bodies as hosts
before bursting out of their chest only
to then proceed to kill everything in
sight then you'd be sorely mistaken
stand down sorney there are no
Xenomorphs aboard this ship no this
slippery little stowaway was none other
than the lovable blob of orange slime
known as SCP 9999 otherwise referred to
as the Tickle Monster known for being an
adorable amorphous anomaly resembling a
pile of gelatinous orange matter SCP 999
has long been considered one of the most
harmless and affectionate scps ever
cataloged it has a habit of honing in on
the nearest person and leaping right at
them not as a means to attack them or
attach any scary eight-legged egg laying
head hugging creature to any faces
instead as C p999 offers a loving
Embrace and wholesome nuzzling to a
person's face all the while emitting
soothing gurgling and cing noises as
well as pleasant sense that change
depending on what the person it's
hugging finds most appealing or calming
while knocked in any way harmful and
only ever acting out of the most well-
meant intentions SCP 999 had been the
one responsible for Pink's disappearance
the Tickle Monster had been discovered
by Pink while he was traveling through a
corridor past the Bay taking the longer
route back to electrical there 999 had
playfully pounced on the crewmate to
offer a hug this had caused pink to
experience the full effect of SCP 99's
anomalous properties slipping into an
overwhelmingly elated state so while not
currently injured he was calmly relaxing
in a hidden corner of the medbay with
the rest of the crew completely unaware
of what was going on SCP 999 had spotted
orange and had been able to recognize
the same color as its own Jell-O likee
body drawn to the crewmate the Tickle
Monster snuck towards orange while his
back was turned busy cleaning out the
filters in the O2 chamber before he
could turn around and spot the creature
SCP 999 leapt to Orange and lured into
the medbay with pink not long after blue
had finished up his latest task fixing
up the wiring and storage brushing off
his hands he began casually walking back
in the direction of the cafeteria only
to see the Crimson of red SPAC suit Z
passed he was rushing down the corridor
almost like he had just been caught well
red-handed something didn't seem right
blue thought to himself red had seemed
pretty indignant earlier when pink had
vanished although he couldn't say with
any certainty if it was because red
really did know what was going on or if
they were just nervous returning to the
cafeteria however the crew quickly
realized that orange was now gone too
I'm calling it now white declared this
was you red you're up to something I
swear I'm not red pleaded it was hard to
see how sincere's expression was through
the tinted space Helm advisor well if
anyone else knows anything or saw
anything then come forward white said to
the group the rest of the crew were
awkwardly shuffling on their feet each
one clearly uncertain but nobody wanting
to come forward and be the first to
speak actually I um blue found thems
saying I saw red dashing around in the
corridor he seemed like he was in a
hurry or maybe he was up to something
maybe look it doesn't prove anything you
don't know that yellow chimed in who
knows he may have been eyeing you up as
his next victim victim red exclaimed
look I don't know what you're implying
here I haven't killed anyone nobody said
pink and orange were dead white replied
unless you know more than you're letting
on I swear I don't know what's happening
I'm just in the dark as you all are red
insisted in that case prove it green
interjected bluntly prove you didn't
kill orange and pink
how red yelled how can I prove that you
could prove they're both still alive
said yellow completely unaware that pink
and orange were actually still alive he
can't prove it white announced solemnly
because I bet they're not even on the
ship anymore the missing crew mates were
in actuality still aboard the ship in
fact they were having the time of their
lives inside the medbay with SCP 999 but
that hadn't stopped the rest of the crew
turning on red come on red blue suck
I mean you've got to admit you're acting
a little well not suspicious but
definitely evasive oh sure what just
because I'm wearing red you all think
I'm some kind of murderous traitor red
shouted his desperate pleading tears
obscured by his helmet's visor this is
McCarthyism look why don't you just give
us a straight answer blue offered trying
to remain reasonable and not join the
rapidly growing Witch Hunt because I'm
scared red insisted scare that we'll
find out white yelled leaping at red and
pinning him down quick the rest of you
you grab his arms and legs a struggle
ensued with red desperately kicking and
flailing about while green and yellow
gripped an arm and leg blue was
reluctant he wanted to urge everyone to
calm down and not do anything irrational
but it was already too late if he
opposed the blame might shift to him
under White's Direction the crew lifted
red up and carried him to the anas's
outer airlock they threw red past the
inside door which slam shut behind him
as he turned and started slamming his
hand against the surface begging for for
them to let him out his pleas fell on
deaf ears as white threw a nearby switch
the outer door of the airlock opened and
the vacuum of space pulled red out of
the ship practically firing him out of
the hull like a cannon leaving him to
drift away alone and with limited oxygen
in his space suit right now that
impostor been dealt with everyone get
back to work white announced we need to
keep this ship in a fit state to move
blue was speechless he thought they were
just going to hold red prisoner in a
secure part of the ship until he calmed
down instead he'd aided his crew mates
in murdering one of their own even the
very thought of it made blue feel sick
and he would have been if he wasn't
wearing a space helmet it all happened
so fast he'd barely had enough time to
consider all the facts after all whiteed
seemed adamant from the very start that
red was somehow responsible for orange
and pink disappearing but he had no
concrete evidence to base that
assumption on then again where were
those missing crew mates they there had
been no sign of them no bodies or
discarded suits maybe they weren't on
the ship at all anymore what if white
was right and red had killed them or
Worse what if White had been the one
responsible and blue had just help him
kill an innocent Spaceman to cover up
his cruel misdeeds of course the
surviving crew were so wrapped up in the
horrifying moral and ethical
implications of the situation that none
of them had thought to check the medbay
meanwhile SCP 999 had found two more new
friends green and and yellow the pair
had seemed rather glum since they had
just helped kill red and so the orange
blob of Good Vibes had sought them out
now the two of them plus orange and pink
who were still fine were all enjoying
the company of the Tickle Monster in the
medbay at the same time though blue was
returning from his task of uploading
data over an admin to find only white
left waiting for him in the cafeteria
neither one of them said anything they'd
both already made up their minds in each
one's head the other was the real guilty
party the culprit responsible for the
disappearances and apparent deaths of
the other crew mates both blue and white
were convinced that the other was truly
the impostor Among Us oh God inrage they
charged at each other rather than act
rationally Maybe by sticking together
and searching the rest of the ship the
two Spacemen engaged each other in a
scuffle you're sus blue roared punching
white in the stomach causing him to
stagger backwards wordss I'm not the one
who sus white wheezed rushing back
towards blue and shoulder barging him
into the cafeteria floor you are you're
sus blue they continued their scrap
trading blows until blue was able to
throw a punch that cracked the glass
visor of White's helmet there was a hiss
as the air escaped and white was
desperately fumbling with his helmet
trying to plug the crack blue was able
to grab him by his oxygen tank and drag
him towards the airlock blasting his
adversary out into the unforgiving cold
emptiness of base blue staggered through
the ship it was certain that he received
a broken rib during the fight and
hobbled along the corridors towards
medbay when the entrance opened he
stared in disbelief at what he saw sat
inside were the entire crew minus the
pair who' been ejected from the airlock
of course pink orange green and yellow
were playing with a friendly blob of
orange slime that seemed to have the
energy and enthusiasm of a pet dog the
crew mates were laughing hugging the
Tickle Monster and engaging in tickle
fights clearly in a state of heightened
Elation in a sudden instant of
realization the horror caught up with
blue he had just murdered white and red
for nothing both of them were innocent
in fact nobody on the ship was actually
missing just before this horrifying
Epiphany caused blue to suffer an
emotional breakdown SCP 999 glided
across the floor towards him smiling as
he knelt to Pat the orange blob on the
head blue suddenly felt better about the
two deaths he'd been responsible for
actually he felt great compelled to
start giggling uncontrollably as he
joined his fellow surviving crew mates
in playing with the stowaway as SCP 999
although thanks to that delightful
distraction not one of the remaining
astronauts realized that their ship was
still a drift in space heading right
towards a sun now go check out SCP 999
the Tickle Monster and SCP 5167 when the
impostor is sus for more blobs and
impostor